Hey look,
it's the kid.
Gosh,
come on it.
Sure,
sure.
I got a shirt on that says the kid case.
You were wondering,
I got tight fitting skin.
It's like how the fighters in smaller font because he gets more letters.
You guys base it on like what's,
what's an even trade?
Did you weigh the ink?
Because the fighter is nice and long but the kid,
well he designs all our t shirts.
I'm terrible with clothing.
I'm not a big fashion.
These to,
you might want to look into someone who actually makes tee-shirts cause that
looks like a fucking junior high school kid did the paintbrush.
That was the idea.
That looks like art class that you didn't give a fuck about passing.
It's karate kid font though.
That's what I'm talking about.
Is it supposed to be like,
like Kung Fu movie fallen?
Yeah,
sure.
Part of the creative department.
I love both of you guys but that is one of the least creative tee shirts I've
ever seen and I love that end thing.
That finer to end the end.
The little fucking weird thing that that stands for end.
You know,
what does that,
what is the thing called?
Is that an Anderson?
That's what I thought ampersand was an a ha like a pound.
Like with the AE that's circled.
What does that at,
what does that,
what does the actual asterik no,
asterisk is the star,
right?
Trying to make tee shirts for my,
well,
which one's ampersand?
I don't know.
Let's find out.
Ampersand,
um,
ampersand and yeah.
Okay.
Jamie's totally correct.
So ampersand is the,
that's the end like fighter and it's a weird little symbol.
It's just slips on yours.
Yes,
you do obviously right there,
man.
Fighter in the kid.
And then that thing over the tea thing.
You just look at it.
You need glasses bro.
I do not just because you need glasses.
Glasses bandwagon.
They could,
you could read shit better.
It's actually called a strudel in Israel.
Okay.
But we're not in Israel.
What was it called in America?
Just the last,
that sign.
That side strudel.
Yeah.
That's one of those ones that like didn't have any play for like hundreds of
years.
They're like,
what does this useless fucking thing bring things back?
You would look like before Twitter and Facebook and all that shit and like in
the name mid,
nothing.
You fucking never used that thing on the keyboard,
on a typewriter.
That was a useless Goddamn k like who the hell needs that and thing you would
ask like,
what is that?
It's some shit you'll never use.
Meanwhile,
some shit everybody uses now.
Everybody's fucking Twitter handle it.
I'm not.
How many
are you a pound sign or a hashtag person?
Well,
you really should say pound side,
right?
I mean,
why is it good to be Hashtag it's the same goddamn thing.
It has a different connotation.
What was a pound signs connotation that it was just on your phone.
Remember Star.
It's like it would be,
you would punctuate the,
send them,
send a,
you know,
a message or so like a voicemail.
Press the pound sign.
That's all,
but they say the LB side,
but then all of a sudden Hashtag came along.
What?
He's making corn beef.
He's slinging,
slinging hash.
What kind of Hash is this?
Twitter has this,
we'd Hash,
how'd you call it?
Hashtag hashtag question mark.
What's the origin?
Someone's going to send us a link on Twitter.
I'm sure the origins of the word Hashtag Hashtag came from Twitter,
right?
Yeah.
Yeah,
and then Facebook adopted.
As I was talking to this,
I was talking to as linguist,
I was saying,
why didn't,
why didn't like southern accents for example in Mississippi,
never go away.
Why did like certain regions hat hold onto their accents and he said most of it
has to do with the fact that you copy the person who's older.
The person you look up to,
if he has an accent,
that's the guy you're going to try to talk like.
So it gets passed down from generation to generation.
It doesn't really get diluted because they just stand up.
More.
Human beings are tribal and so what they do with you,
if you grew up around your dad or your older brother or somebody who look up to
who speaks a certain way without even realizing it,
you start taking on their language.
You speak exactly the way I do,
same intonation and everything,
and so what happens is that accent in Louisiana will always stay that accent in
Louisiana.
It's really interesting,
but then that can,
that can start to sort of change as much as people migrate a bunch of bad
motherfuckers,
bunch of Badass big Dick.
South Africans came in and just fucked everybody in the town dominated,
came in with billions dollars of cash.
Who'd be interesting,
if there was a way where you could restructure an accent,
just a few dominant Alpha chimpanzee males with a strange accent,
you know,
strange South African accent.
Like if there was a way,
like some bad motherfuckers could move into an area,
well if everybody would want to be like them so much,
they would start talking like South Africa,
if you go to Barcelona in Spain,
they,
they talk with [inaudible] and they say that is because the king had a list a
long time ago and everybody started to copy that sort of,
you know,
that,
that colloquialism or whatever.
Well,
it is kind of weird that Lyft is considered to be od the one strange sound that
you make,
but roving,
the autos is considered to be flamboyant and beautiful.
Like if you say someone who speak the Queen's English,
of course I didn't know,
but we have like that we have like categories we'll,
we'll put like this is a sound that you should make and this is a sound where
it's fucked up.
It's,
I don't like it.
And it's all based on our control.
See the list of the issue with the list.
Busy.
Some people cannot control the fact that they make that sound,
so they're not trying to lift.
You have very difficult for them to not live yet.
But so because of that,
that sound becomes inappropriate.
Yeah.
Maybe it's because when
you have a list,
it's already quote unquote a defect.
So it's considered a weakness.
So that would be something that is,
well,
it's just because he can't control it.
That's why it's a weakness.
If he rolls his ours on purpose,
then it sounds cool.
He's undoing of,
but not us.
But if he wrote,
you roll your eyes because you can't stop like you're at the scanner McGregor,
but keep calling them [inaudible] Connor,
I can go into a little bit of his home with us and that's a different thing.
An Irish thing.
But yeah,
the RS are slippery,
right?
Yeah.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Yes.
What if that was a disease,
you know,
instead of a lisp.
Right.
You know,
it was always got a Ross Perot.
Oh,
the poor bastard content of the speech impediment.
Gutters.
Gutters or neurological starters,
Huh?
Yeah.
That's a neurological thing.
There was a kid that,
uh,
I used to be friends with and his brother have stutter,
poor,
poor bastard.
It just fucking just would lock up,
man.
He would lock up in front of you and you'd want to like help him through it and
you have to act like nothing.
My,
that something about status in deer.
Me To the person,
like I want to protect them.
We had a guy in my taekwondo school who would,
sometimes we'd line up and he'd have to say Chartio,
Kanye to like now and he could hit such a bad stutter.
So we obviously there and you go check up
and we have to wait sometimes for 40 seconds.
Wow.
But of course we all did.
And something about a stutter has always made me feel protective over the purse.
If you're stuttering all the time,
she,
you be getting kicked in the head.
That's seems like a good question.
You got a,
you got shit going on there already.
Some bad connections.
Maybe you could rattle it loose like you hear about those stories were like kid
gets in a car accident and all of sudden they could play music.
Yeah.
Well there's a Robert Sacks to the thing about this guy who got struck by
lightening is regular dude got struck by lightning and became obsessed with
music,
especially the piano and just didn't literally did nothing but play 12 hours a
day and think piano and,
and,
and he was convinced it was a sign from God.
And so Robert Sacks said,
well,
you know,
it may be a sign from God but is there any way I can study your brain?
And he said,
no,
no I,
this is Scott and I'm not interested in the scientific.
And he was just such a bummer for him.
Cause like what the fuck happened?
What happened that you got struck by lightning and you became obsessed with the
piano where he literally played all day.
I think he's probably scared that if you find something that's wrong that they
might like fix it.
Well I took it back to being normal.
Well it's very strange to me also because what they find with people who like
when they say something like,
oh you've got to follow your passion man.
Problem with that is that you've got to broaden your passion.
Cause sometimes you're passionate would be just what you know.
And a lot of people consider their passion of what they're just good at already
or they,
they came at it with us,
the right,
you know,
emotional state.
So it was easier for them to learn.
But some passions you have to work at really hard before you get good at them,
like math or for that matter even like boxing,
you know,
or something
like that,
but so,
right.
But why would you think that he would want to not have his brain examined?
Oh,
I think that was absolutely just superstitious thing.
I think that he kind of felt he,
it would go away if somebody did something to his brain.
I do.
I was with Sachs said,
I mean in effect,
I would wonder if he would be afraid that it was purely psychological.
Like this is my,
I think there's a lot of people who say they believe in God and they'll talk
about the fact they believe in God,
but I don't know if they believe 100% I think it might believe like 80% 20%
haunts them.
Don't,
they don't want to address that 20% and when something like this happens,
whereas a tangible effect of a physical act and you attribute it to God.
If someone comes along and says,
no,
you're Abdula Mangala,
whatever,
the gut fried,
you don't have that part of your brain anymore.
And that part of your brain dictate social skills.
Like if you have a hard time like talking to people.
Yeah,
well you lost that.
That part's not there anymore.
So you're basing,
you know,
all of you,
all your attention is now going to music.
And if you found out that instead of like God gave you a gift,
that would fuck with your head.
That's right.
Well a lot of they say that people who,
the fundamentalists,
people who are,
you know,
they believe and they're willing to die for their beliefs.
There's always a great deal of doubt,
way more dealt with those people.
How much fucking mental illnesses there in this world.
You know,
it's something no one wants to bring up.
No one wants to bring up like how much of believing in unbelievably ludicrous
shit is a type of a mental illness.
The first question though also is this,
I mean if you say,
I believe in God,
I actually think a better question initially is what is God?
First of all,
how do you define God?
Yeah,
I mean as God,
what they thought he was when they were riding on animal skins or can we define
God as there's,
there's obviously a better look,
there's,
there's a way that feels good in this world and there's a way that feels bad in
this world.
What feels bad?
Tragedy,
disease,
injury,
pain,
suffering,
violence,
crimes,
stealing,
taking advantage of robbing that.
Oh,
did you hear what that fuck did?
Oh this guy got fucked over.
Oh this guy got beat up.
Look at this video.
Fuck this guy got this.
That's obviously the worst way to go.
I mean we feel that right?
But positive is like you see friendship and you see happy kids playing and you
see people smiling cause they enjoy the self sacrifice.
Barbecues you see,
you see like prosperity and friendship and kinship.
You see all this good stuff.
And so if you just,
obviously if you just live your life more towards the good stuff is the most you
can.
That's like a godly life.
Yeah.
It's like if that's the rational life,
right?
That's what they called it.
Does that what they called it?
The rational,
like in other words,
you,
as long as you stay within what would be considered the rational.
So,
so if you,
um,
but it's right there was
wrote,
Roman law was kind of predicated on,
right?
So if you park your chariot in an area where they do in Carthage and you get a
ticket and you go to the judge and you say,
Hey Roman judge and Carthage,
we park our terrorists this way in the room.
And judge goes,
okay,
well in Rome we do it this way.
So try to do,
try to do it that way,
but did this way delineate,
delineate the law.
Then a man comes along,
snatches the baby out of woman's arm and kidnaps at our kills it or something.
And all of us go and he'd go,
well,
I know we do that in Carthage.
Well,
what the room would Roman law would say is we don't,
well,
whether you do that in Carthage or not,
doesn't matter because this is outside the bounds of rationality.
This is outside the bounds of nature.
This is an unnatural act.
And so Romans,
they were Cicero.
CICERO was a father drawer in fighting people and fucking each other in the
cause because they also had,
they also had a massive empire that had to be run according to set up a set of
principles,
you have to have something that doesn't make sense.
Everybody's idea of what that is depends on tiredly upon what happened to them
when they were young.
It's what you're exposed to when you're really young.
If you find out about the vast majority of people that commit horrific acts,
like a good chunk of them had some serious trauma when they were young.
Whether it was someone sexually molested them or someone abused them.
There was a lot of abuse.
There's something wrong.
The only,
there's a few of them that people can't figure out.
Like you know,
it was a big one that they have a hard time to figure out.
Jeffrey Dahmer Dahmer apparently had like normal parents that that's sociopath
gene that there's been so much research recently written on this.
In fact,
a Barbara Oakley wrote a book called the evil jeans and,
and they really looked at at how different serial killer brains and they think
that there is for sure something that goes on genetically with sociopathic.
John Wayne Gacy and those kinds of people.
They actually,
in many cases,
you can actually tell they have a different brain than do regular people.
And there's a lot of science now about that can be extreme sense.
If you look at every body type there is,
look at all the different flaws that people just are born with.
Like,
like me,
like I've,
I've been a Lego,
so have spots where I don't grow any pigment around my knuckles.
Bigger Hanson Brennan shop,
keep calling it.
But yeah,
it's very giant has evolved.
I've got a lot of issues,
but that's probably not,
that's probably not bad.
It's just the guy gave me freaky bones.
Right.
But the bad stuff is very minimal.
You look at some bad stuff that people have,
like we know people that are dead.
We know people that had cancer and died.
We know people that are born with like degenerative arthritis.
You know,
um,
Sean rouse,
I mean that poor bastard.
I mean,
that poor bastard is always in pain and he's a fucking funny dude,
man.
Rouse is funniest shit.
He's really good.
And He,
kids always in pain.
Every time you shake his hands,
she's like,
you know,
you just want to be as gentle as you can and just,
rheumatoid.
Oh,
it's bad dude.
It's bad.
It's an auto.
And we just got new knees though.
Yeah,
you got to get his knees posting,
man.
Fuck,
he's in his thirties.
Yeah,
Dude.
He's,
you know,
he just,
the genetic roll the dice.
It just said he got fucked.
And so my point was there's so much variation in like,
you see people with dwarfism,
you seen people with gigantism,
there's variation everywhere.
It just would only make sense that there'd be variation in the structure of the
actual brain itself.
Some people are born with weak eyesight there.
Their eyesight's sucks.
Right out of the gain is a physic,
physical body.
I mean it's,
it says,
no reason to believe that that,
you know,
first of all,
evolutionary biologists have come to the conclusion that the brain,
our brains are different.
I mean,
you're not born a blank slate.
Here's the big question.
Here's the really big question.
This is the one for everybody.
This is a hard one.
As medical science reaches a certain point where they understand the components
of the brain far more clearly than they do now.
Cause like,
you know,
one of the themes that we've had on the show the last few days,
I had the scar fattiness Russell on and um,
he was,
he was talking about how just like a hundred years or so ago,
the way people would look at certain races was radically different than the way
they look at them now.
Like in medical journals and shit.
The way they would describe Irish was that they were like basically like apes
and they would do this in like Harvard.
It was really fascinating conversation.
We know now that's ridiculous,
right?
We know now that there's brilliant people from every single race and it's the
big part of it is what do you expose to,
you know,
what kind of genetics are you dealing with and you know,
what kind of curiosity do you have in your family?
What w w how do you develop what makes us so you're nurtured versus your nature?
Yeah.
What makes a sprinter,
does that disqualify him from being a brilliant thinker?
No,
it doesn't,
you know,
those ideas are,
those ideas were in the past.
But if there was a way where they could examine your brain and go,
well this guy has no empathy,
this guy completely lacks at the end.
He gets an enjoyment out of torturing animals.
If you could find Sarah doing that.
And in fact,
what they found is a lot of serial killers have underdeveloped,
uh,
McCullough's so that almond shaped that part of the brand and believes that that
floods with Serotonin,
et cetera.
And a lot of them have smaller than normal or they're damaged and it's,
it's hard for like,
one of the things that they talk about serial killers a lot of times is for them
to feel is sometimes close to impossible.
They've got,
it goes into extremes,
but sexual sadism and all that stuff,
is that what they call,
um,
what this guy had the great famous profile or Richard Walter Calls,
uh,
a power excitement.
So people who get off on the,
some people will kill you,
overpower they want to kill you.
But,
but when somebody has been torturing somebody,
they get off on the act of killing,
not the killing,
the act of killing.
And that's,
those kinds of people have,
they think have different brains that just get off on the power and they're not
feeling any remorse.
They get sexual pleasure from putting people in terrible pain.
Do you,
here's the question.
If they can spot that,
I mean how weird is the world get?
Why are you going to let that guy live?
Like we would all have to look at them like it's no different,
in my opinion,
than having a vampire that lives in your neighborhood.
If you had a vampire in your neighborhood and the vampire was constantly
compelled to feed on human blood,
how long would it take before everybody rallied the troops and stuck a fucking
stake in that vampires heart?
It would take.
That's a very,
that's a very good question.
The first day.
Now if you found a way to absolutely identify a serial killer,
like this guy is a fucking serial killer.
This guy's this die.
This is what's important to him.
This is what he doesn't give a fuck about.
This guy loves killing.
He loves torturing.
Get doesn't give a fuck.
Yeah,
you'd have to kill him.
It would be like having a vampire,
right?
I mean,
wouldn't it be this or it'd be another thing.
How about this?
By the same token,
what you,
what would you would have to say about somebody like that is they have brain
damage.
Their brains are damaged.
They are not working like an irrational human beings.
So you want to fix it?
No.
Well,
either you fix it or you categorically look at it the same way you would look at
any kind of a d,
a birth defect or a handicap.
What that means then is what does that say about punitive punishment?
Do you punish them or do you put them in a hospital and keep them in a padded
room?
That's the other question.
Well,
what kind of a life is that?
I don't know,
but,
but whatever you do,
let's just say that we can prove their brains are different.
This is a physiological thing they had no control over.
But at the end of the day,
they have urges.
They have no control over.
Say the way.
Somebody who gambles really badly now what now?
Now,
yes,
they're killers.
They're horrible.
We want him dead.
Frankly,
it's a sick dog well to human being.
So what do we do then?
What does that say about punitive punishment?
Do you punish them or do you put them in a hospital,
uh,
and put them in the room with a very sensible John Wayne like character who's
going to say,
why don't you guys step outside and you hear a bang?
He went for my gun and then go home.
That's what happened.
I would agree.
I think it's spirit can't write a law like that though.
Experiment on him is not a bad idea.
Using monkeys use humans cause you can't,
you can't write a law like that because it's not consistent.
It's inconsistent with how about this?
Every time you experiment on him,
you let him kill an asshole.
You take like a child molester and every time like the serial killer,
you let it like you'll try some new birth control on them or something.
Every time you let them kill a child molester.
Yeah.
Well Richard,
Richard Walter,
that FBI profiler was the guy who kept quite,
came up with a double helix,
whatever he called it of how a serial killer,
he interviewed 20,000 murderers or something like that.
And what's really fascinating to hear him talk about how serial killers come to
be,
so how they start and they start in really weird ways.
It starts with some
kind of fetishism like,
like rubbing up somebody against somebody in a,
in a,
in a bus stop or they call it p carism.
Sometimes I'll find like when a cop hears about somebody who cut up a bunch of
leather jackets in a store,
Ooh,
they'll go,
hold on.
We want to come in there and look at something.
Because what Richard Walter would say,
it says a lot of them who were into just cutting people,
a lot of them started by going into department stores and doing terrible damage
to all the fine leather by cutting with a very sharp scalpel.
And they got off on the fact that first they could get caught.
It's very expensive,
they'd be in big trouble.
But also they,
it's the feeling of skin.
So,
so then what happens with serial killers,
they said is that you keep going and you keep needing a bigger and bigger fix
and you never go back from that.
Like you never are able to reverse the perversion.
So once they have,
once they upped the ante on up the ante on,
so finally they kill,
you're never,
they're never going back.
Never that,
that urge continues to come back more and more.
That's John,
that's what Ted Bundy would talk about.
Well,
one of the most terrifying ones was the Zodiac killer because he was obviously
super smart who would write things in code.
He would leave them messages to crack and an author write letters to the
victim's parents of families and he never got caught,
never got caught.
They don't know who that guy was.
There's all these different fucking speculations.
None of them,
you know,
seem to be 100% they have some idea like,
people said that was my dad.
People said I know the guy,
but the,
whoever the guy was,
he had to be above average intelligence.
Very,
very smart.
Which is fucking terrifying.
That someone could be very,
very smart and just wanting to say this,
just want to fucking kill people.
Yeah,
and they're out there.
It's,
it's the sort of,
I look at it as like,
um,
what does that book the Mom,
do you ever read the Ma the demonic male about chimps?
Uh,
actually apes and how human beings are bipolar rapes capable of incredible
kindness and incredible cruelty.
And maybe,
and if you look at apes,
they'll do that.
Like chimps will fucking kill each other and bite each other than they're
incredibly caring of the young sometimes.
And we're a bipolar rape,
you know?
Um,
but,
but that,
that could have a genetic,
uh,
usefulness apparently like the variation in genes,
one extreme to the other,
one extreme being,
I don't know,
mother Theresa,
the other extreme beam,
Jeffrey Dahmer,
and we all kind of lived somewhere in the middle.
But geneticists will tell you that you need both extremes,
you know,
to create the mean.
It's pretty fucking,
you know,
you start getting into this science and you're like,
God dammit,
we start thinking about that.
If you,
if you think about needing both sides,
like is that exist everywhere in the universe?
Is there a hot Nicole,
he's there.
Yang,
is there always an evil and a group group?
The it doesn't,
does the evil make the good better?
Does it make it feel better?
I mean is that a part of the whole thing?
I think it was enough to write and it was like we were talking about,
um,
people who were born into or with Rory yesterday where Albany's hilarious guy.
We're talking about people born into money and that when people were born into
money that never happy.
They just can't,
they can't do because everything's always been handed to them.
They,
if they don't earn it,
if you don't feel that struggle of being broke,
like I think you and I appreciate everything we we've earned because when you
were young you can clearly remember that,
you know,
you were fucking trying to pay your bills and doing odd jobs and there was
always longing,
you know,
it's kind of jobs that you,
Judy,
you worked in a bank for a while.
I worked in Mcdonald's,
I worked construction for a summer in DC in the middle of the summer.
Your story about working in a bank was so,
uh,
so on,
cause that's 16 months to waking up when it was still dark,
put it on nylon socks.
I literally,
I thought I was going to die.
I,
I started to become,
I started to dislike myself.
I was,
I was being,
I became,
I wasn't even an incident when I was eating anymore.
I became a bad person.
But that's how you got out of it because you're your soul,
whatever.
It was trying to not panic.
I said I have to be an actor.
I ran into my friend's room.
I go,
okay dude,
I'm quitting everything.
And that's what I have.
I had a dream,
you know,
I'll tell you an amazing study.
I'll tell you an amazing study on,
on your point in nine in the 1930s,
they did this five year study on Boston school children and they took,
do you know the story?
No,
but I'll tell you right now,
80% of our twats no,
those kids get off me.
You little fuck you might be right.
Dixon twats but it's a really famous study that had far reaching implications,
which was they took two large groups and for five years they gave one group a
great deal of support,
uh,
money,
psych,
psychological help,
tutor,
tutoring coaches,
and the other group,
they left completely alone and it came back 30 years later and looked at both
groups and the group that had it,
five years of that kind of special attention fair was faring far worse and had
much higher levels of alcohol abuse than the other because the other group had
to rely on the s become self reliant and that required all the other things now,
yet you have to be careful because sometimes you can damage somebody,
but certainly self-reliance and,
and not learning helplessness,
but learning the opposite.
So fucking important.
Well,
it's,
it's there right in front of our eyes.
We just want to ignore it.
Like what'd you just said?
You have to be careful with the stress because you could damage somebody.
Well,
that's like analogous to working out like,
yeah,
you could hurt yourself working out,
but if your idea is to just stay a piece of veal in a room that's padded so that
your body doesn't ever move and get injured or get strong as shit so that you
know,
you could do a lot of things with your body.
Yeah.
Like what would you rather like?
Not Be in pain all the time and not like,
I like feeling your body deteriorating.
Right.
You know,
I don't mean sore from working out.
I mean like when you're,
when you have nothing,
you have no muscle.
Everything is just mush and Goo and slowly gravity pulling towards
the bottom.
Well,
that's what happens if you don't ever risk exercising.
The same thing with your brain.
You build neural pathways in your brain.
You can literally build them.
Yeah.
I would think that with everything in this world,
you,
you can either resist and then grow stronger because of resisting or never
resist and have this like apathetic way of approaching whatever the fuck it is
you're doing.
Like everything you do,
everything you do is hard to do.
Everybody's like,
Oh,
you know,
it's really hard making watches.
You know,
it's really hard.
Everything that's done well.
That's right.
That's,
it's really hard.
So true.
Everything is done.
That's so true.
That's why that thing,
dreams of Sushi movie is so fucking interesting because who gives a fuck?
The guys just make it Sushi.
Like I tried to get me to watch that his parents didn't like him.
Remember?
Yeah.
He said my parents didn't like me.
Yeah,
that's good.
Tries him actually he looked like he was going to cry and he was 90.
When was that expression that they use?
What's that expression to use?
Where a guy who's just a complete master at something,
I forget what the expression,
well I stroll or no,
no,
it's a Japanese expression,
um,
that they were using to describe how this guy who had worked so meticulously on
creating this egg dish,
he remember he was making that egg dish for like a year and he just couldn't get
it right.
And one day the guy,
you know,
said you got it right and then gave him this Japanese,
see if you can find it.
Whatever the fuck it is from the movie.
Jiro dreams of Sushi and see if you can find what that was one of his,
it was one of his apprentices who just kept having that there for controlling
the custard away.
Finally.
Got It.
Right.
They have this weird egg dish they make and it has to be perfect.
It's like,
I'm not sure how they're doing it,
but eventually,
eventually after a year,
this guy got it right and he was so happy.
He said he cried.
Show couldn't show Koonin yeah.
Show congeal.
Koonin what is it?
What is the definition?
Does it have like a Wikipedia definition was,
it's a show.
Koonin she'll cook here.
I'll show how spell it.
That's h.
Okay.
Show Koonin the Japanese word show.
Koonin.
Okay.
Did that guy that didn't really translated,
uh,
artists and craftsmen who feel deep obligation.
It's why I don't like pedal it political correctness because I think it's a lie.
I think we were,
we,
you know,
we live in a culture that is always telling you you have to feel good and I
think anything worth it,
anything worth it,
it takes exactly what you're talking.
I don't think there's anything wrong with wanting to feel good.
I think the real issue with political correctness says that it avoids intent and
it,
it ignores the complex subtleties of human communication.
It ignores the reality that one person could say something.
How about this?
You can say something one time and it's offensive and you could say the same
thing when you're in a better mood and a better situation and it's hilarious.
You could be in the wrong state of mind when you say it or you could say it
clumsily and don't accept it.
You can know.
You could say it after something that people might think it's insensitive if you
said it,
they're not willing to go along on the ride with you.
Or You could say that same thing in front of the same people in a different
circumstance and they get how laughing.
I think you're the funniest guy ever.
I can't believe he said that.
All My god,
he's so crazy.
The political correctness in applies as you apply it to humor.
The big issue,
the number one issue is that humor is almost always about something you didn't
expect or something you can relate to.
And both of those things,
something you can relate to,
you're telling me you can't relate to racist stuff.
Like,
look,
there's certain amount of racist stuff that's fucking hilarious,
including racist stuff against white people.
Right.
When Richard Pryor used to do that,
we know,
oh,
your Mama motherfucker,
my mom,
she's a great old Gal.
That is a racist joke that's making fun of white people that are goofy.
You can't even,
oh Yo Momma,
motherfucker.
You can't,
you can't even say that to them at work.
I mean,
that's racist.
Is it?
Or is it racial?
Is it only racist if a white person does it and racial,
if a black person does it?
I mean,
what is it?
It's,
it's a type of humor.
Yeah.
Well there's,
there's,
I guess the difference in racism and bigotry.
Bigotry is an individual thing,
right?
So I'm bigoted.
You can be banging it against fat people or whatever.
Whereas racism,
just the definition applies to the institution of racism.
So you're a rat.
So that's why it was always used more sensitively to black people in this
country at least.
Because when you live in a racist society,
the institutions themselves are stacked against you because they were racist.
That's why you can't have a white pride shirt,
but you can have a brown pride shirt if you're Mexican or chain Velasquez was
tattoo.
That's right.
Like Roy Nelson joked around like fucking glass Glasgow's and had a white pride
tattoo on his chest,
like the brown pride on canes chest.
What would anybody be able to do?
I mean,
there's something to that,
right?
But there's not,
because of course,
no one owned white people.
There wasn't a bunch of white people that were kidnapped over in Iceland and
thrown onto a fucking slave ship and dragged over to America.
Your texts was so funny about,
I don't know if I can even say it,
but when I was like,
they're honoring women in film.
Can I say it?
Yeah.
Say you're like,
you're like a women in film having women always been in film and then you go,
what did they have?
What if they honored white men in film?
I wonder what would happen then?
What?
What kind of an uproar that if you had an thing honoring men in film,
right.
Especially because you could do black men,
black men in film like that would be like a,
like a real black tie affair.
You would go there and dressing your best but on your shiny shoes.
But what I said was you said it's women in film,
like aren't women in every movie,
right.
The basically in every movie crack me.
How many movies don't have women?
Well they all to you like,
haven't they always been a movie?
He said always an f at forever.
I was like,
yeah,
they have,
I mean,
yeah,
they've done some awesome shit.
I don't have a problem.
This is my issue.
I don't have a problem with them honoring women in film at all.
I have no problem.
I point out like what if they want to do white men in film because I know that
there would be a massive outrage.
I except the fact that people want to honor only women in film.
I accept the fact that I bet for women it's pretty fucking frustrating sometimes
because I bet a lot of movies that women go to or just not geared for women.
You know,
there's a lot of movies,
like if you go and see,
you know,
transformers that was,
that's probably geared towards anybody.
They'd probably cut that bitch right down the middle with stats and graphs and
they probably get phone calls and fucking brought in people to analyze it.
They probably cut that bitch right down the middle.
Men and women,
they'd probably give you just enough mushy bullshit so that women go Google for
my girlfriend would say,
Ugh,
if I go,
hey,
let's watch transformers.
That would be her reaction.
She's smart though.
What they were honoring deer hunter.
Yeah.
Like here's the movie,
the deer hunter to fucked up movie man.
Chicks don't want to see a movie.
Whereas Mau,
Mau,
they've got the fucking gun by the head and you know he's eventually gonna shoot
himself and they're playing there became an actor that I became an active
because that same,
we keep calling this fucking amazing movie and you never see the deer hunter.
It's one of those movies from the 70s but is it like 71 or something like that?
One best picture in 1978 was it that late?
Oh Wow.
Why did I think it was it?
Either way.
It's from an era where a lot of the movies don't hold up.
Yeah.
Those seventies movies,
man,
some of them are tough to watch.
Not the fucking deer hunter.
Holy Shit.
That's a good movie.
That was so beyond anything at the time.
Yeah.
Shocking.
When he shoots himself in the head and grabs him know,
oh are heartbreaking.
Cried when I saw that I was at an age where I just thought,
first of all,
I took movies seriously and second of all,
I never got over that.
I was like,
ah,
I don't know what that is.
That movie was incredible.
That was Robert De Niro.
When he was a mother and a great,
the greatest at that point.
And Christopher Walker,
he was a motherfucker.
Motherfucker.
Yeah.
Christopher Walken.
You give them a good role.
He's still a motherfucker.
He still carries this creepy power to them.
I watched that.
Uh,
the,
uh,
awesome scene from pulp fiction.
Um,
I know romance from True Romance.
That's the great scene.
That's the greatest thing.
I didn't really like the scene in pulp fiction.
I was like,
I get it.
The watch was up your ass.
I loved it.
I didn't buy it for some reason.
I love the movie,
but I'm like,
that seems like,
come on,
get out of here with this watch.
I know.
Again,
it's up your ass,
you know,
I dunno,
whatever.
For whatever reason,
it didn't work for me,
but him and true romance.
You know who I am,
Mister Wally.
I'm the antichrist.
You got me.
And they'd been let it kind of mood what to do,
a little Q and a at the risk of sounding redundant,
try to make the answers genuine.
So it was so creepy when he did it too,
because it's the words like the tone.
It's a very originally Christopher Walken type of delivery.
I had never,
I couldn't believe that saint,
I was like,
what?
I said,
we'll do a little pantomime is the pantomime guy.
He gives himself 17 whatever it is,
17 different movements that girls 21 but anyway,
it just goes through this whole where it's like this fucking Pool Hustlers,
movie pool hall junkies.
As people tried to tell me that was good.
Oh God.
Fucking awful.
And this scene,
the lion in the jungle,
it's not a good scene.
And everybody told me it's like this.
It gives us great speech.
I'm like,
Oh that movie is dog shit.
Yeah,
people would still recommend it.
Like was awesome.
King of New York was great too and he gives a speech was amazing in that.
The problem with that pool hall movies,
no one could really play pool.
They're all like whacking balls around and shit like they don't,
they're not really playing pool.
You can't have a movie where you don't even teach the guy out to play pool.
It's got to look at least a little bit like you can actually play pool.
This is offensive and it's just like,
come on,
this is like,
it's so goofy.
The guy who doesn't want to get the job,
it's like,
why do you like pull so much?
I have no idea.
Yeah.
I learned it at a formative age,
you know,
learned it.
Uh,
when it's,
it helped me transfer a lot of focus and energy that I probably would have put
into bad places.
Yeah.
You know,
man,
you're good.
You ran a table I think three times man.
Shop or like just try it on a table three times.
It's kind of,
I play a lot.
I got this table right here.
Yeah.
It's a stupid thing to get good at.
I totally freely admitted like people go more golf.
But you play pool.
Did I mark everything?
I mark my own family golf cause she'll get,
yeah,
I'm playing golf.
Mock everybody.
I mock myself,
I mock you.
I mocked me.
I mock golf,
I mock every fucking thing there is.
I'm on Mock Pink Ribbons for breast cancer and walking for aids.
I'm mock at all.
Everything's Mokbel birth can suck my dick.
Every one of them I'm mocking.
Bird sold me with their freedoms.
I'm down with mockingbirds get it.
Come on.
I mean,
I think the more I can laugh,
the better.
And I find the,
the happier I am.
Like I was listening to a Jim Norton on the radio today on the open Anthony
show.
He's telling a story of him and Jim Florentine about how Jim Norton was jerking
off in the backseat of his car while they were driving home from a Gig.
He had met a girl and he was so excited.
It was so funny.
I was fucking crying,
laughing because he had met her and he wanted,
he wanted to jerk off before he got together with her.
What he,
no,
no.
He met her and it didn't work out.
He hooked up with her,
like,
you know,
maybe like touch,
she touched him or something like that.
And then he had to go and he was so fired up that he had a jerk off.
So he jerked off in the car in the backseat and they were telling the story and
was fucking hilarious.
And they were telling the story how is busting each other's balls.
And it was,
it was genuinely enjoyable for both them and for me,
it's like,
it's fun.
Listen,
but people don't,
you know,
there's some people that just can't handle it.
I want to be laughing or learning everything else in the big,
in the middle I was like boring.
I guess I'll eat and sleep,
but over there all I have a problem with being stupid.
I love being stupid,
but they have a problem with it.
You know what I mean?
People don't like being,
because
a lot of times when they're being mocked,
there's no humor to it.
Or if there is a humor,
it's a very mean humor.
Like there's some humor that's just not fun.
It was back to that same thing about politically correct.
Can we laugh at it?
You know,
every academic I have on my podcast,
you know,
I love having all the academics,
every single one of them,
every single one of them says basically says to me,
what kills me is how politically correct I have to be in my classroom.
If I'm not,
if I'm not,
I could get in huge trouble.
So if you're a Harvard,
Yale Faculty,
you better be speaking for everyone,
including Paul Pennies and tribes.
And you know,
I mean it doesn't matter man.
If you say anything,
if you even say it,
it's just an unbelievable man.
And that's the number one complaint I hear from him.
Okay.
But here's the big question.
This is the sort of,
the question that I had with Thaddeus Russell,
and we talked about it yesterday with Rory too,
is is this a sign of some sort of social progress that we're like springing back
so far?
The other way that it's just,
it's,
it's rebounding like some of the loss ground that was given up when they,
when they had things like separate fucking fountains for men.
When women could get raped,
no one would do anything about it.
When cops would literally ask someone,
what were you wearing when you got raped?
I mean,
all the different things that have happened,
all the different times that people have been homophobic or you know,
outwardly sexist,
both from towards men and towards women,
that the bigger the reaction that is happening now like this,
this big below back,
this big politically correct,
left wing,
progressive push that may be,
it's just like the waves of the ocean,
like we were talking about earlier,
the Yin and the Yang,
that you need the evil to have the good and sometimes you need the good to just
blow the fuck up.
So even the evils like,
okay,
I think,
I think the answer is yes,
that the wave is,
is pushing in the other direction.
However,
it's a good direction.
It's a good direction.
However,
you've got to make sure it doesn't.
It doesn't,
it doesn't get too crazy.
It doesn't become it's own form of tyranny and it doesn't get in the way of the
truth.
Also,
you have to realize that some people,
they use an ideology to get out their aggression and they can choose to decide
that it's relevant or justified.
And in doing so what they are is stressed out,
fucked up people who have a lot of tension in their lives and they have a cause
and they find a cause that they agree with that makes intellectual sense and
then is supported by other people and then they aggressively pursue that cost.
The point of calling people out and being nasty and vicious,
what are they really doing though?
I'll tell you what they're really doing.
They're using a cause to be an asshole.
Why?
Because they're assholes.
They're assholes that support a good idea and they're doing it totally the wrong
way.
And in doing so the wrong way and being super aggressive and asshole ish,
what you're doing is you're strengthening up the resistance to that.
So if your asshole ish,
like in a right wing sort of a way,
you're going to make a bunch of asshole leftwing people that are forced deal
with your bullshit,
right?
But consequently,
if your asshole ish from a left wing point of view and you want everything
politically correct and it's not,
it's not freshmen,
it's fresh people.
I mean you're,
you're dealing with that kind of shit,
which is stupid nonsense.
I'll give you an amazing example of this.
I mean,
and it became a fierce,
fierce debate when,
when,
uh,
you're right.
No,
no,
fucking terrible.
The Sally swing.
Oh,
for heaven's sake,
he spilled his coffee everywhere.
I didn't spill it out,
like actually kept the coffee in my hand.
There it is.
Not Bad.
Not Bad,
but it was my Sally swing chair,
which I love is a,
on some serious rollers.
Very good.
I got it.
It was very little coffee.
But this is,
this is a classic example of one of the biggest debates,
intellectual debates,
what,
which was the,
when it used to be that everybody would talk about human beings and it was,
it was sort of married to a Marxist ideology.
The idea that human beings started zero.
We are all a blank slate.
So every child is what is a blank slate and whatever you socially put on it will
actually be so.
So who says boy should play with guns?
They should also be given dogs and we'll make the world a better place and
people,
men won't be as aggressive.
And the question is learned.
It is an inherent and innate.
That was the dogma.
And then a bunch of evolutionary scientists started doing a lot of,
uh,
a lot of work.
Like Steven pinker and Steven pinker wrote a book called the blank slate.
And a large part of the book is chronicles the,
when the evolutionary biologist who studied,
for example,
the,
uh,
what are the names,
the Yanno Mano that take up a hundreds of tens of thousands of miles in the
Amazon basin.
The,
the,
the men that had killed more in battle sired more children had more wives.
And when that anthropologist came back with that and said,
I'm studying indigenous cultures here where aggression not only is seems to be
natural cause not exposed to the western ideas of what it,
what aggression is,
but they fight all the time.
They,
they had a lot of tribal warfare.
It also,
when they come back to their tribes,
it also seems to be that they are more attractive to females.
Well,
when he came back and said that the people that had held the blank slate theory
went crazy and attacked all those guys,
attack that guy in a number of other people.
Uh,
they attacked him personally,
called them liars.
They're fudging their data and everything else.
Of course.
Now we know with Steven Pinker's work in these guys and almost all evolutionary
biologist agree that you are born.
People are born like we were talking about with different proclivities,
but human beings,
pretty much every culture we've ever studied,
they fight what direction is his humility?
It's malleable.
Human beings are malleable.
Yes,
they have very ideally the,
they have tendencies that tend to be exhibited in their relatives and especially
in their,
and we've known
that with dogs forever.
The fact that we think that it doesn't exist in humans when it exists so clearly
in dogs like Joe,
the guy bought Johnny from the massive,
yeah,
he won't breed a dog if it's aggressive to people.
He won't let it breed.
He'll fix him.
He'll fix the mail and if it's a female he'll get her fixed too.
And he just,
if anyone,
that's a trip that they exhibit any aggression towards people done any direct
aggression towards dogs,
not interested,
not interested.
What let them breed.
So because you've met my dog,
he's the sweetest dog ever and he's so nice.
He's just so gentle.
Like my four year old would play with them and I don't work and he's like
fucking big dog.
But I never worry about scratch and crawl,
fight and hunts for existence.
Do you don't think that aggression is going to be an evolutionary necessity?
It is.
Well how bout dogs?
How about the dog that you used to have?
Ah,
came bread.
Exactly that crazy dog like a fucking doesn't goats to go to a baby cow and
broke the legs of a German shepherd.
And what?
What was up with that dog?
That dog was being bred for fighting.
That dog was a whirlwind.
That dog couldn't wait to get its teeth on something.
That's what it lived for.
It was hypercharged.
It was like it was on 10 all the time.
I loved that dog.
I'd go over here and it was a little dog too.
That's what people don't realize.
People both skinny be called the real pit bulls.
They used to fight them where they apparently still do the parts of the country
that like 35 pounds.
That's a big one.
Yeah.
They're small dogs.
The big ones get tired apparently.
Like those big dogs.
It's just like UFC fighters like to see those big dogs that are like the,
those super monster pit bulls.
They would never fight that as they fight the little separate.
Tim Kennedy's,
he seems never to.
Ted Kennedy seems to just grind you down.
He's a fucking tough Prek.
Ah.
This is a tough Prek.
What'd you think of that?
What?
What are they going to,
what did you think about that?
A,
I'm sorry to jump over now,
but no,
it's okay.
Yeah.
For folks who don't know what we're talking about,
Yoel Romero,
who is this
dud wrestler from Cuba?
Two time world champion.
Yeah.
He's one.
He's won a metal in every single wrestling tournament he entered pretty much.
I mean,
he metal,
he was a silver medalist in the Olympics.
He medaled in the world cop.
I mean just,
he's a fucking freak wrestler.
Cael Sanderson was grace one of the greatest amateur wrestlers of all time.
Yoel Romero beat him twice,
twice.
I mean,
he has that much of a freak when you see him in the octagon.
I almost wish,
cause he's only 30,
he's 37 years old.
I almost wish we got him when he was 27.
God,
you know,
I mean God,
10 years of that guy in MMA.
But it was hard for him to get over from Cuba to America.
Um,
but he fought this Guy Tim Kennedy and for the first round he was beating that
ass.
He was beating Tim Kennedy's ass.
It was just speed and it was connection.
He,
every time he would hit Kenny,
but Kenny so fucking tough.
Okay.
So fucking tough.
He,
his strategy was just to make this guy work,
to stay there,
gang in asam gas.
I'm out.
And so he starts attacking in the sac around and you see Ramiro braking.
You see him slowly started to get exhausted,
and Kennedy is just working him constantly working.
I'm constantly making a breathe and then the end of the round he cracks some.
But if you didn't see the controversy on Kennedy's side,
there's a video of Kennedy Holden Romero's glove pull this video up.
What?
Kennedy Holds Romero's glove.
Oh boy.
But it's put,
it's like there's an animated Gif that probably would show it just as good.
It's hard to look at and be,
um,
be like a objective about it.
Because if you look at just the instance where he's grabbing the glove,
it clearly looks like he's cheating and he's landing a couple punches while he's
holding onto the inside of someone's gloves.
So they can't use their arm.
But when you watch it,
it in real time,
in the full context of the fight,
you realized it was a fraction of a second.
Yeah.
And there was haymakers being thrown.
He was holding onto his arm and it just so happened that for Latin,
not even a second,
he had his hand inside the glove.
Okay,
but that's,
that's not,
that's just a photograph.
You want to see the animated Gif cause the animated Gif,
he goes from that,
which is he's holding the wrist wear.
The glove is,
which is totally acceptable to,
as he's punching for a brief moment,
his fingers went in there,
but then after that is when he connected with some pretty big shots at the end
of the round.
Like I honestly,
I'd looked at it a few times.
Very objectively.
I've had,
see what's,
let's play it again.
Play it again from the beginning.
I'll,
that's a split second.
He's just fighting and not only that,
this is all in slow motion.
It's a split second in slow motion.
So let's see it again.
See,
grab bome it's like not even a second got caught.
I think it looks like that he was sliding down.
He was in the middle of fucking combat.
That's what was going on.
He was a beast right there.
Just swinging toffee is,
he's got it.
He's got a hold of the glove man.
I don't know.
It looks like it's a problem is it's happening in slow motion.
It looks like you found it.
Well,
he definitely slid down,
but one too.
I want to know how,
see the thing is though,
in the real fight,
I don't even know if that was like he realized he was holding it and he let go.
I mean how much time was he holding it?
Let's see if he could find the real videoing.
And right now he doesn't forget about this because this,
this is not even half speed.
We need to find the real video.
Find the real video.
So we will look at it in real time.
But look,
I was calling it,
I didn't notice it.
If I noticed that,
I would have definitely said something.
I thought that a very short time,
even in slow motion,
it was way more fucked up was that Romero was sitting on a stool in between
rounds.
They didn't make him stand up.
They didn't take a stool away.
There was 29 seconds between the end of the second round when he was fucking on
Queer Street.
He was on the corner of Queer Street and Queer Boulevard.
He was right there crying.
He got fucking rocked man.
He walked back to his corner liquor drunk.
That 30 seconds is giant.
Whose fault is that?
Well,
you know,
they said like 10 Kenny was saying his corner put too much Vaseline on them.
See that's what's wrong because it's the corners that use the Vaseline.
It's the UFC cut man that use the Vaseline.
And so the UFC is science cutman weaves the same cut men for every event.
And we just,
yeah,
yeah.
Impartial cut man.
I mean I certainly have friends and they,
you know,
I'm not saying it's impossible that someone would leave extra grease on,
but I think they left the east extra grease on his life cause he had a giant
cut.
I saw his cut man.
His cut was huge.
Get a huge cut where his eyebrow was like a good solid inch and a half long.
It was a big fucking cut and it was bleeding and so they closed.
They stopped the blood and they put the the Vaseline on it,
but that's just what they do.
The thing was,
John,
he recognized the Vaseline and start talking about the Vaseline mostly because
Romero was still on the stool and people were still in there,
so he was correcting them already.
He was saying,
you got to get out,
get out,
seconds out.
Let's go,
let's go.
Let's go.
He's got too much Vaseline on like he,
if Ramiro was standing up,
they might've said there was too much Vaseline on and it would have taken two
seconds for them to wipe it off.
Turn two of them.
Good.
Okay.
Fight like a few seconds.
Yeah,
but he still sat on that stool.
He sat on that still just sat there.
[inaudible] he knows her.
Tim Kennedy's in front of them going,
what the fuck?
Get up like what's going on?
And he's still just sitting on the stool.
That should be it.
They should've.
John should have called the fight right there.
Did you?
You can't just sit on the stool.
Why didn't you take the stool out?
This guy is,
but he doesn't want to do that.
See,
because if he does that,
then the fight doesn't go on and everybody misses the finality of,
and they get mad at him.
They got mad at him.
He was going to knock him the fuck out.
You shave the bullshit.
It's right.
So I think John did.
John wanted to,
he knew we wanted to see more fun.
Don't rob us of the fighting John.
But you can't let that happen.
And it's like you don't expect it to happen.
But I guess you have to be diligent with a some corners who they know,
they know how to fucking get their way out of a situation.
They know that they can look.
Angelo Dundee was on the greatest trainers of all time and when Henry Cooper was
fighting Ali Henry Cooper cracked.
I'll leave with a left hook.
He had a vicious left,
took Ali's legs,
gave out and he fucking crumpled.
And In between rounds,
Angelo Dundee realized that Ali was out.
So he cut his gloves off.
Yup.
Right.
Here we go.
Is this a real time?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's see.
In real time.
Back it up a little bit because that's,
that's wait.
Yeah,
that's good.
This is just a highlight reel,
so,
okay.
Let's see if we can see that in the highlight reel.
Boy.
What's up with youtube?
It's mostly this laptop.
Is it really?
Yeah.
Hmm.
Hold on a sec.
Well,
now that we have those new things,
can we not use the laptop?
Now that we have the new connection,
Jamie?
Different.
All right,
we'll fix that man.
Tell me what to do and fix that.
Tired of that stupid laptop.
So I talked to bullshit.
Bullshit.
It's funny,
man.
Laptops have a couple of years ago.
They just don't want to deal with all the new shit.
You're a techie.
What about the iPhone six I'm not a real techie.
No,
no.
Not by any stretch.
You have caps on sex.
I'm a tech fan boy.
Fanboy.
Ask.
Yeah,
true.
But I don't really know much.
There you go.
Here we go.
Real life.
Yeah.
That's holding on.
That's real.
Yeah,
that's real time.
but that's,
that's real time slid down it.
Hockey definitely did,
but he was definitely holding the glove the in real time.
But again,
um,
did he realize he was doing it?
It's,
it's,
there's an argument could be made that he didn't realize he was doing it,
but there's also an argument that can be made that he had to know when he's
doing it,
but he's fucking in full animal frenzy.
Right.
There's a difference between that and not getting up off the stool.
Getting off off the stool is totally a hundred percent calculator.
There's no animal frenzy at all.
That's like two and a half punches though.
Yup.
No,
it's totally legit.
Just moving forward.
Let's talk,
I mean,
if you wanted to time it,
I mean it might've been assessing strategy though.
I don't think it was.
I'm going to grab that glove.
It doesn't feel like that.
It feels like he bought a number of times for the hand.
It's enough time to know that he's holding it and then he lets it go.
See he's holding onto it.
Boom.
Yeah.
But the first one was,
no,
the first,
no.
The first one he's holding wear.
The glove is that's legal,
right?
You're allowed to hold the glove.
What you're not allowed to do is this,
Brian,
put your fingers inside the glove,
right?
That's what you see.
You're,
you're misjudging it.
It's probably not if you're saying a bunch of punches,
but that's not the case because he's holding the glove in the beginning.
So he's holding the wrist and the glove.
Then as Romero is trying to pull away some of the fingers go into the glove for
a second.
But you're incorrect.
Correct.
If you think that it's illegal to hold the gloves,
right.
So I think that's one of the reasons why people think this is more grievous than
it is.
I don't think it has at all.
If,
if you,
if he knew what he was doing,
it was one second less than that.
If he knew he would was doing it is illegal.
It's illegal.
What he did for sure,
and it is in the middle of this fucking battle royale right moment where he's
connected.
So you know,
I holy,
he knows whether or not he knew what he was doing.
I would imagine when you're a fighter and you're in that wild scrambled for your
life against a stud like Yoel Romero,
yeah.
You're probably in a pure animal state.
Yeah.
Just reacting on instincts.
He's been smashed in the head.
Who knows how many fucking times in that first round and in the Sacramento,
me Ramiro cracked him with some big shots and he's a spooky Stryker and then at
the end he knocked him out.
Ramiro Ramiro sitting on the stool like that is a way bigger.
Controversial.
Then Tim Arrow new,
the round was over.
He knew the round was over.
He knew he was getting extra break.
100%.
Yeah,
1000 million percent.
He was sitting there,
Kennedy was in front of them saying,
what's going on?
Get up,
get up.
And he's still just sat there.
Yup.
I mean that extra 29 seconds was fucking gigantic because after this is over,
this fucking combination,
boom,
and look at this one.
Bam,
Bam.
That lasts left and right hand afterwards and another one,
dude,
Romero can take it like almost nobody I've ever seen.
Amazing.
He fucked Derek Brunson.
Derek Brunson.
Head kicked him.
Coleen switch kick to the head.
Boom.
He ate it like it was candy didn't even buckle,
dude.
It was crazy for war.
Totally built for war.
Did he got Shinde on the neck and just ate it like it was nothing.
It's so ridiculous.
It's so ridiculous because I remember watching that fight.
I don't believe I called that fight.
I think that was a Kenny Florian fight,
but I think I was watching at home going,
get the fuck outta here.
How did that guy got hit with that?
He just,
he just ate it.
Different human being,
but he didn't even tumble like whack.
I get what?
What?
No,
he looks as close to a superhero as you get.
I mean you don't get more feed out.
It's just ridiculous.
There's a picture of Romero with Hector Lombard and Tiago al.
See,
it's the most preposterous picture and it's like there's so ridiculously
muscular.
What kind of jeans are you dealing with?
These gladiator genes or these three guys have even Tiago looks somewhat
diminutive next to those guys like Jack and little lumbar.
He looks like a normal dude.
Almost like Antioch was far from it.
It was unbelievable.
Man.
Next to her Merrill and Lombard,
there's someone above them,
Cuban jeans,
man tube and jeans or something else.
Different things.
And Oh,
by the way,
you've been,
you've been throwing dudes around your whole life.
Yeah.
On a high level.
Well,
there was that boxer from the 1970s I believe his name was Teofilo Stevenson,
Stephen's or Stevenson,
but they always wanted him to fight Ali.
They always wanting to get him from Cuba.
He was like,
this amateur would win all the amateur tournaments,
and everybody was like,
this ain't fair.
Because Americans get to a certain level.
They're amateurs.
They get to a certain level,
they turn pro,
but the Cubans never turned pro.
So they're always amateurs,
but they're being paid by Cuba.
So you've got these guys were in their late thirties when boxing their whole
life,
fighting 18 year old kids and just lighting him up.
And that's what you had with like the Cuban boxing team.
And everybody would say,
oh,
the Cuban box teams the best look,
without a doubt,
they're very skillful.
Very skillful,
but recognize that they're competing far longer as amateurs than anyone in
America.
I mean that's just what it was.
And then when Solon,
the Americans were still winning like in the 76 Olympics and Mark Brie Lind and
Pernell Whitaker and Meldrick Taylor.
Was that 76 was that Roy?
No,
76 was Ray Leonard.
That was 88 80 88 was it?
I think it was 80,
I think it was 88 who are 80 80 1980 year mark.
Mark [inaudible] 88 wasn't it?
Was it rise?
I don't think so.
Whatever happened to Mark Wheeler.
He's a,
he's coaching people now,
Huh?
Yeah,
he um,
1984.
Oh,
okay.
Gold metal in 1984 Olympics.
Yeah,
he was a bad motherfucker.
I just rewatched them product.
The point is,
those were all,
those were all kids.
Those were all kids that took on in some countries,
like,
you know when you were facing Cuban boxers and amateur tournaments or sometimes
there's Soviet Union.
Yeah,
there were grown men.
They weren't going to fight professionally.
There was no professional fighting.
You know,
that was always the deal with a certain Soviet boxers,
but Soviet boxing has really taken off now
with kinetic cannon and the other guy's phone.
Man.
It's a whole shitload of them.
Who's going to fight?
Who's the Russian?
I keep forgetting prop to cough or whatever.
Who's going to fight?
Providing the cough?
I,
no,
no.
That's not his name.
The guy who's going to fight Bernard Hopkins.
Max.
Yeah.
Killer.
He's a bad motherfucker.
I don't remember his name.
I just saw him fight a few weeks ago.
Can I think of that?
No.
Connecticut off Glenna is the middleweight guy,
right?
Yeah.
He's,
he fights it 54 or something.
Let's say Bernard Hopkins.
Next fight.
Yeah.
That Russian guy's scary,
but Hopkins is a ridiculous freak.
Colette,
Sergio Colaveccha,
Colt Kovalev.
Sergio live calls.
I love.
Yeah.
He's a beast.
It's fascinating that Bernard Hopkins is still boxing the shit out of these guys
though.
At 49 years of age and hunting going after guys.
This,
this guy who hits it was,
I don't think he's,
I think he's not that everybody's fought.
Yeah.
Including killed a guy in the ring.
What?
Yes.
He killed the guy.
He did.
But let you get that.
That's a fact.
For Real.
Yep.
How'd he know this?
I've read about him.
Cova live killed a man.
All right.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
Killed a man called wow.
It's,
if you Google it,
it comes up really quickly.
Yeah.
So He's a killer.
Wow.
Hard hits.
Boxer dies in the ring.
Yeah.
His name was Roman Simak cough.
There's a video of it.
And Kovalev didn't give a fuck.
Well,
I don't know.
I mean,
I don't want to say that,
but I mean,
he certainly didn't,
it didn't hurt his boxing.
He just kept boxing.
That's what people are terrified of.
Right.
Can kill a guy and then go right back and be just as good.
And he's got really weird power.
I mean,
he really hurts dudes.
And if you see,
we'll see what happens when there's highlights of when he hits him and they just
go,
what,
what's this?
Oh,
I'm getting hit.
this is a different thing.
Totally hit by a sparring partner like this or in the gym.
This is different.
Yeah.
And Golovkin is kind of the same way and had a left can hits that hard,
like,
yeah,
there's a lot of those Soviet guys who could just fucking crack you.
It's weird.
Well,
they have an excellent,
the amateur system is so good.
It's just like the Cuban system.
Yeah,
and poured it and a lot of them,
they're starting out.
Let me see that.
Is that the,
the fight where the guy died?
Oh,
pull it up to the beginning.
That's bad.
Sometimes guys also,
and this is a reality of boxing sometimes guys come into the,
the ring itself already damaged from sparring.
No one's job was talking about how he used to spar with Shane Carwyn and he
would have fights and he was fucked up when he went into the fight.
Like he said,
when he fought a Ben Rothwell,
he's like,
dude,
I got Kod.
Just like not long before the fight by Shane sparring with Shane.
It that they say that a lot of boxes were ruined in the gym wars.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
I mean,
guys have died in gym wars too,
by the way.
100% this guy's a murderer,
man.
He's,
I mean,
I didn't mean that and that way I meant like he just hits the road.
He didn't mean to kill.
This guy obviously was boxing.
You know,
it might not have been his fault at all.
I mean,
like I said,
that guy could have gone into the cage already fucked up.
Yup.
It's very po into the ring rather.
Yeah.
It's very,
very possible that he had a preexisting condition.
It's very possible that it was from all the damages he took while sparring.
It's very possible that he cut a lot of weight in tragedy.
It's awful.
I hate seeing that.
Like a great a fighter who gives his whole life and then it's just the worst
man.
How about when Roy Jones Jr got carried out of the ring and now we're seeing
them fight again.
He's back at it.
It went to sleep.
Oh he went,
he was in total parallel universes that the one with Glen Johnson.
Yeah,
those are the,
that's the damage that you,
they say,
you know,
walk away from,
that's the scary one.
You go out for a long time.
Like when Manny Pacquiao got my mark has knocked it,
hit him with that left hook or whatever.
I mean he was just,
it's not just getting hit there and then falling on your face.
Yup.
That's bad too.
You know,
that's probably as bad.
That thing that happens to guys when they bounce their head off the canvas.
Yeah.
That's just as bad.
Cause you see like when a lot of guys get like viciously knocked out,
it's one of the things that that does it.
I remember when I'm,
Mike Mccallum fought Donald Curry.
I used to be a big Donald Curry fam.
Donald Curry was a sick boxer man in the 1980s.
He was sick.
He had just wicked technique.
Man,
he's just threw everything perfect.
It didn't have like a big build.
He wasn't built like,
like a monster.
It just ha you just was a wicked athlete and it really good boxer.
And um,
he uh,
he cut weight against this Guy Lloyd Huntington.
He was,
he had a really hard time making one 47.
And that was back when they just did not know how to rehydrate people correctly.
They just did a terrible job of rehydrating people.
And so he had to go up in weight class after that.
I just fought like shit.
And after that he was never really the same again.
It's like that one loss one one time get beaten up.
And one time of like losing the confidence of being the best pound for pound
fighter in the world.
He was considered the best pound for pound for awhile.
And um,
then he fought Mike Mccallum and Mike my column hit him with this left hook to
the body,
left hook to the chin,
wham Bam.
And the ones that Chin just sent him flying backwards,
his head bounced off the canvas.
Blam so Ricky Hatton,
Ricky Hatton versus down.
I've seen he got shut off his whole Ang you saw in slow motion.
His whole head looked like an accordion.
Yeah.
You know,
what should we published four knockouts now in the UFC or has it stayed the
same?
People are getting better.
If people are getting better,
it makes it tougher to hit people,
but they're better at hitting people.
It depends on the matchups really.
You know,
there's,
I think there's less people that fight in the UFC now that have one very
specific discipline,
you know,
and they're missing the other stuff.
Like you'd never see those,
the grab where's that?
Can't strike it all anymore.
They're all,
everybody's dangerous on their feet.
Everybody,
every,
I mean,
they're not
equal.
It's not equal.
Yeah.
But there's a lot of God damn dangerous dudes.
It's very few people that have that glaring hole in their game.
So you can't just go in and just beat the shit out of him.
You got to set them up just like everybody else.
They're athletes.
They move very fast and if you fuck up and they catch you with something,
you can get in big trouble,
especially early in a fight.
So I think that people are just better all across the board.
There's,
there's better athletes now than there's ever been before.
Guys.
Like,
like McGregor coming up.
I,
Conor Mcgregor,
he's a fucking kids,
a tremendous athlete.
Wonderboy Thompson.
Just see that that fine.
I didn't see that fight.
Jesus Christ that kids could.
He's great.
It's fucking striking.
Striking.
Since he was like three literally,
and he's all point style.
His hands are down on this dance sideways.
Nobody can get on.
I'm getting on them.
You're eating knuckle sandwiches on foot kicks.
Oh,
I have your thing.
Throws front leg side to the body,
throws vicious leg kicks,
throw his head kicks.
I mean he's fucking good.
He has 57 and oh kickboxing record dude.
57 57 and Oh,
and he's just starting to figure out the MMA game he's trying to get,
he hasn't even so called Avalon.
Right,
exactly.
Yeah.
You see what?
I think he's a purple belt or a blue belt in Jujitsu is his brother in law I
think is Carlos Machado.
One of the channels is brother-in-law,
so he's,
you know,
he's been involved in martial arts essentially his whole life,
but it was mostly this a striking.
So now you're seeing them learn to avoid the take downs and once he's learning
to avoid the take downs,
he's able to create much more comfortable on his feet.
Now he's getting loose.
Fuck Dude,
guys landed some ridiculous combinations.
Man.
Mr Dominick Cruz,
it's looking pretty good.
Ooh,
insane Brent and tell he trained with him one time he and chilled train and
Dominick Cruz and both of them at the end of the session they were,
they were like both basically quiet cause Dominick Cruz is so smart.
He was like,
no,
when you do this you do this.
And he was showing them stuff and they were like cow smart as this fucking guy.
He's very smart.
He's very focused,
you know,
I mean you,
you see that when you pay attention to his analysis,
he's very good at analyzing.
Like he did a great breakdown once that I thought was really important for
people to watch a young fighters,
especially of when Conley knocked out rich Franklin.
And he shows like the error that Franklin made.
Franklin threw a kick and the counter,
like he was right in line for the counter.
He didn't move his head off the center line at all.
And I'm like,
this is so important that someone like draws us in a Dj.
He had a diagram,
you know like one of those things and he's like showing,
you know,
he's like pointing to the big screen and pointing out all the different,
because his hand has always,
always to the side.
It's almost like Tj Dillashaw like you know,
like he and Dwayne watched Dominic,
you know.
Oh what they did.
Oh they did.
Of course that's going to be a fun fight to watch.
Very fun fight to watch Tj if anybody's emulated Dominick style of movement.
A lot of it's Tj.
Yeah.
But Dominic took it to a totally different level the other night.
He,
he looked like he was on like he was from another planet.
I mean he was like that.
That was seriously like the next level technique.
Like next level aggression.
Next level proficiency,
next level accuracy.
Very good.
Really.
Mitsa [inaudible] he's top five.
Wow.
He's number five and number six contender.
Yeah.
Mitsui [inaudible] he's very good.
Very good.
Cause what's one instinct in me has a lot of guys who shine another division,
other like organizations come over to the USC like watching Dallas Serone in
that fight against Eddie Alvarez,
Alvarez and Eddie Alvarez is a kid,
wasn't any hours that belch chimp from us while he's just lost the time.
You didn't lose the title left and the title and then watching when he comes
over to the UFC and watching how what Donald's Ronnie did to him,
it was a real eyeopener for me because he looks like such a,
he is a killer and he's a great fighter,
but Donald's a different level.
Donald's got real moy Moitai that real Muay Thai is different than these guys
that want to be boxers who just occasionally throw kicks.
There's boxes is occasionally throw kicks and there's guys who have left hook,
right leg kick ingrained in their genetics.
When Donald's Serone hits you,
the left kick to the liver,
you better lift up your left leg to check.
If you don't,
he's coming down hard on that thigh with that Shin.
He,
he hooks with the left and then chops with the right and it's,
it's in his DNA,
dude.
He'll throw that straight,
right,
left hook,
right leg kick all day long.
And you will be in that moment because you're moving away from the left hook.
You move away from that left Hook,
you step to your left to avoid the punch that coming from shy down.
And he chops that right leg kick right on your thigh.
And he's as an overnight.
He's timing that knee every time you go in for a single leg,
good luck.
Boom.
You know who does that awesome as Josie Aldo.
Yeah.
They called the Duchy,
the yell out in his corner,
the Duchy,
the Duchy.
Cause it's a classic Dutch combination.
Dutch kickboxing being like one of the most talent rich countries ever for
kickboxing was Holland.
Like beyond,
above and beyond.
So many great fighters came from Holland.
It's almost insane if he thinks Nesto who's Badr?
Hari boss.
Rutan um,
rob came in who is arguably the greatest of all time,
uh,
Ramon Dekkers who's also are arguably the greatest of all time deckers and boss
wouldn't you when you think the decker bus route and it's like one of the
greatest strikers to ever enter into MMA.
And one of the reasons,
cause he had that MMA striking training from Holland,
it was all like dealing with high level kickboxing training.
You know,
Peter Arts,
I mean just you can get,
keep going on and on and on.
The great kickboxers that came out of Holland,
the training in Holland,
even guys who aren't from home,
like Tyrone Spong,
he learned in Holland,
he developed that Holland style.
But Melvin Manhoef,
Collin Keller monsters,
there's like the kickboxing is so high level there man,
just ridiculously high level.
So they would always call that out the Duchy,
the Dutchy and that's that left hook left hook to the body,
right leg kick.
Aldo throws it like a fucking Ballerina.
Crazy.
It's like art form.
When he throws it,
it's like,
Ooh.
Like he just spun in the air like it was doing a,
like he was a figure skater or something.
He's trying to say.
I want to see that I'm dying to see Mcgregor.
Although now of course who isn't well I'm dying to see Aldo versus Chad Mendez
to men.
Mendez has improved.
It's striking.
But uh,
although is always a motherfucker,
man is going to have a hard time because he's so short and stocking.
It feels like he's going to have a very hard time getting close to a McGregor
man.
He just fights it a different distance.
Yeah,
well that's why we want to see them fight.
You know,
it's always interesting when someone has a big task to deal with.
But the other task is we've never seen McGregor fight.
A guy who's a monster wrestler like Mendez Mendez,
a super athlete and a monster wrestler.
Like what happens in,
he gets taken down.
How,
how well does he fight off of his back?
How well does he do when he gets Clegg weeded,
let Kuwait Clegg Weda did Anthony Pettis just stuck on them like blue and
dragged him to the ground and made a stalemate out of it.
What does he do then?
And that's a beautiful thing about watching contenders with various styles go at
it is that you get to chance to see like from a strategic standpoint,
there's so many variables.
Like there's kind of,
there's some variables and boxing and kickboxing,
there's movement and different combinations you could throw.
But the variables between striking and grappling and the transitions between
those two or what makes MMA so fucking exciting and some of the things that
people boo at and they get bummed out about like a Clegg.
We'd up stifling Anthony Pettis to the point where he can't get anything off.
Those are good.
You have to see though,
cause you got to know that a guy can do that.
Because when you see a guy like Conor McGregor was just running through
everybody,
you go,
okay,
what happens if you fight a guy who just has a lightning shot that you can't
stop?
Like Josh Koscheck and his prime.
A guy who just like lightning shot.
Yeah,
just drives you across the cage like you're a fucking pillow and tosses it in
the air and slams you on your back.
You're like,
oh,
next level shit.
Different.
What do you do?
How do you react?
Yeah,
and we don't know that yet.
That's one of the cool things about watching different styles.
Go at it.
You don't know what the fuck is going to happen.
I mean,
Mcgregor could hook,
kick him in the face.
He could do something crazy thing.
He threw his hook kick because firstly I don't think I've ever seen that in the
essay.
Very rare.
Straight up taekwondo hookah.
Yeah.
I mean cro cop's thrown a couple,
but it was almost like,
it was almost like this is how much respect I have for you.
I'm going to hook kick at you.
If you are good at it,
you've got a good chance of landing it because people don't expect it.
Right.
It's like this Guy Larry Kelly,
we've talked about him on the podcast before.
He was a guy in Boston that was known to have a really good hook kick.
He was known for it.
Bill,
super foot walls,
had a really good hook here.
This Guy Larry Kelly,
back when Billy blanks used to be a point fighter,
he hook kick Billy blanks and the head and sent him flying across the thing
unconscious.
One of the greatest.
The one thing I never find it Larry Kelly Kaos Billy blanks.
I know we've shown it on the podcast before,
but it was,
it's a weird kick to get good at because it's an awkward movement of the body,
but if you practice it,
you can get it like everything else.
Like the wheel kicks a wheel weird kick.
Yeah.
But once you learn how to distribute your weight properly and whip yourself
through it,
it becomes like easy or at
you can use ingrained,
you can use it.
Yeah.
So same thing with the hook kick.
I never really developed a good hook,
kick me any of that.
I used to hate practicing it.
It was always a thing we used to be like,
all right,
here's hook,
Keck,
let's move on.
I want to do round house,
but it's good though.
I just,
I wish I had,
you know,
like here it is.
Watch this is,
this is crazy.
Boom Dude.
Hook,
kick to the face.
What's the,
what's that one more time Larry Kelly was,
uh,
I was living in Boston and this guy was,
um,
Laurie Kelly plan one of the karate guys that you'd hear about in the western
Massachusetts area.
He was like one of the best at this style,
this point style of karate fighting,
which there was some,
boom,
look at that shit.
Thought it was gonna be a slide side kick I think.
Yeah.
And he's just slid back and caught a right on the job.
There was a bunch of those guys who was Billy blanks and there was a couple of
other guys that,
I don't remember the name.
There's one guy named Mafia Holloway who was this big yoked up black dude who
was like super fucking fast taekwondo guys.
When you watch like someone that's took karate guy so he kicks so hard and I
mean if you get caught in the head with those cakes like we'll kick roundhouse.
Good luck.
No dislike.
Yeah,
there was a lot of those guys very,
very fast and especially if you try to fight him at that style because that
style,
what it is they,
they were lunge in,
they hit each other and then they break the action up.
It's real weird.
It's like,
but there's something good.
The idea behind it is kind of silly because the idea is really based on this
notion that karate man,
it's too deadly to ever land more than one punch.
And that even when you land like they would get,
people get in trouble for excessive contact.
Like you can hit too hard,
you'll get disqualified.
But I think it's funny that tie to karate,
taekwondo,
those,
a lot of those moves like Hook,
kick and slide sidekick and roundhouse,
you know,
the way they do it in taekwondo or are kind of just becoming more relevant now
in MMA.
But what I was really good to have distance.
What I was going to say is,
the good thing about the breaking it up is that you have to learn how to close
that distance.
The best way you can like that was the emphasis was entirely on closing the
distance and landing.
The emphasis was not on doing anything after that.
So once they learned how to close that distance,
like Ruth with ridiculous speed,
if you fight people that are used to only continuous fighting,
oftentimes that's not something they're good at because it's too dangerous.
You don't just launch yourself across the ring at somebody.
Cause if you do,
you get get fucked up man and less.
You're really good at launching yourself across the ring and being evasive.
And one of the best ways to do that is to learn how to play tag.
And that's essentially what these karate guys are doing.
And if you can learn how to play tag way better than anybody else,
that's how fucking giant advantage.
And that is what Conor McGregor is doing.
That's what Wonderboy Thompson is doing.
What these guys are doing is they're incorporating a point style of fighting and
the people who are used to that Moy Thai style or a taekwondo style like in
point fighting like you know,
or um,
uh,
continuous fighting there.
They're not used to it.
They're not used to someone who launches themselves like such fluidity across
the cage like that,
that Hook kick,
no,
you reaching,
he wouldn't do that in a more Thai fight.
No,
because you would never develop it that good.
Right?
Cause the to have that as your approach over and over and over again,
it's really ridiculous,
right?
Somebody is going to know what you're doing and then going to chop your leg,
but they can't when you get so good at it because you've done it to this
incredible level of proficiency.
So they develop like a,
it's a weird jump and this is the same thing with taekwondo in a way,
because of those lot of taekwondo take techniques developed because they don't
allow leg kicks.
Cause if they allowed leg kicks,
a lot of the shit you do wouldn't work.
It was one of the first things that I learned when I started kickboxing was that
there's two things that I suck at.
I suck at getting kicked in the legs and I suck at boxing.
Right?
Like when I was outside kicking distance,
I was good.
But when guys get close to me,
I would be flustered.
I didn't know what to do.
I got punched in the face a lot.
I got my leg kicked.
I was like,
Ooh.
Well that was,
that's what's so different about Conor Mcgregor,
which I didn't realize he was a national champion.
There was a national amateur champion as a boxer,
which I didn't know and they never really talk about it.
And UFC,
you never see that really in his credits.
But he was,
he won the nationals.
Well,
it's his,
he's kicking.
That's almost more impressive what I'm saying,
that he's one of the few guys who can kick and then when he's in there,
his hands are amazing.
Like he doesn't have that problem.
He's a good,
he's an excellent boxer,
is an excellent boxer,
which was shocking to me is how well he's picked up the kicking.
He's like throwing a hook kicks and spinning back kick,
like that's his opening moves.
I really think,
I really think a lot of it is like he truly is after in a such a single mine in
way such a single in my way the championship,
that's all that matters and it's the next level,
next level,
next level guys.
There's like,
okay,
here's the new evolution.
The next level guys,
a guy who was a wicked boxer who's got an iron chin who fucking totally believes
in himself has charisma coming out of every fucking porn.
His body.
Oh,
and he can knock you the fuck out with any hand and he calls it.
He predicts it like Ali's predicted he's going to knock out the number five guy
in the world with within the first round trying to get it dressed to the nines.
Yeah,
he's hilarious.
He's awesome.
Fucking love the guy and a guy like that,
man,
that's next level shit.
That's like everything that Jon Jones has failed to do with the public.
This fucking guy has done without even winning the championship.
Kratovil it's fascinating because like a lot of people,
like I've always tried to figure out what it is about someone that makes people
like them.
It's so hard to tell man,
you don't know what the fuck it is.
Like I never saw a guy like McGregor coming.
I never saw that.
I always felt like,
you know,
I've seen it rise up to the hype.
Right?
So it's one thing to talk a big game.
It's another,
when you are actually championship material,
when your skill level and you're doing what you said you do,
when you,
when you predict the first round knock out with a guy like Justin [inaudible],
Dustin,
I mean dust to Christ.
Now I'm terrible.
A fighter pot.
I know,
I know Dustin play,
I keep saying Justin,
but I mean,
that guy's a killer,
you know?
And he did it.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Yeah.
He just got caught up in the,
in the headlights.
You know,
Mcgregor is no joke.
He's really good.
And again,
he's next level who you are at that way.
And what was he saying to them?
It wasn't the way I was in Toronto.
Yeah.
Um,
he's uh,
it's a,
it's a fascinating time for martial arts man.
Really interesting time because all of these techniques that were thought to be
not like pivotal techniques have become pivotal techniques like front kicks to
the face.
That's not even a flashy technique.
But once Anderson Linden and on veto or all of a sudden it became like a number
one technique and then uh,
Brown landed on the Alster,
he landed it in that fucking,
oh my God,
it's v tour or not a veto veto or getting knocked out by Anderson.
But Randy getting knocked out by Machida jumping front kick,
but she took it to the next level.
I want to thank that Mississippi has a golf does me in front kick so crazy that
these techniques like that.
No.
And now Thompson does like a lot of like front leg round kicks.
He does a lot of weird shit.
He sneaks kicks over behind your shoulder and then chop.
No,
Wonderboy,
Taiwan's Stephen Thompson.
He's doing a lot of like weird,
interesting karate kicks.
Yeah.
Josh Thompson's got some serious kicks too.
He's like the first guy to stop Nate Diaz in the octagon.
He had kicked him.
Yeah,
that was fucking nasty.
So it was a dish.
It's funny he has really coming back to fight Anderson Silva.
Yeah.
When is that?
January.
You want to be there?
Come on.
I've got a show.
Do the show.
Uh,
and um,
the Mirage,
um,
at the Mirage.
What,
what day in January,
whatever.
It's like whatever.
January 2nd or January 1st probably.
I'll figure out a new year.
Show anywhere.
Yeah.
Where yet?
I'll be in Bora Bora with my family.
Why?
It's so you're never going to make a show in Vegas.
It's new years.
Oh Shit.
What are you retarded?
What are we talking about here?
I kept thinking it was after that.
This is Brian,
by the way.
He'll tell you I'll be at your party.
Maybe I'll tell you,
hey,
I'm going to be in Russia for a month.
What are you going to come to my point?
You RSVP you dick.
You don't know.
Well,
that's why you're funny.
I'm in Bora Bora.
Speaking of which,
I'll be in that.
I liked her responsible people.
I'll be at the Atlanta Improv October 17th just plug it like that.
That's weird.
You were talking about where you'd be.
No,
no,
I didn't talk about that.
I just happened to have,
she's like,
wait,
okay,
we're talking about fights.
You want to be there for the foot.
Do you want me,
when do you want me to,
not October 16th 17th and 18th right.
Tickets aren't sale for my thing yet.
No,
no.
I'll cause I'll be in pudding and then trying to bring in,
yeah,
probably that's where you have for what New Year's?
No,
I'm with my family.
I was talking about October.
What are you going to Bora Bora.
What the fuck is dad's taken?
Everybody.
Christ,
family,
kids and everything
tall.
I was like,
really?
All right.
I never been.
I get nervous on vacation.
I just not good really taking it to get nervous and I just,
I just get restless.
I can't hang to here's,
here's the reality.
Our life is way more fun than average.
He get to be a goddamn comedian all the time and like it's a Friday night and
there's no show.
You look at your watch and go,
shit,
I could be on stage right now.
It's like crystal.
Yeah.
Crystal.
Leah was like,
if I'm not,
why would I do anything?
Why would I talk to you dude when all I do is crush?
And
he was like,
you know what,
I crush and calm.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
How about Chris living in a good old pocket there?
I was loving it.
Just,
just his,
his Instagram cracks me up and he's just fucking love and stand up and just sell
it out.
Selling out all over the place.
It's nice to be in a place where everything starts clicking.
I see guys like him.
Everything is clicking.
It's all firing together.
It's cool to watch.
Yeah,
man.
I've been watching a lot of standup over then the last,
last few weeks.
Really?
Yeah.
Watched Katt Williams special and I uh,
I enjoyed it.
It was on a lot of people.
Some people were criticizing and I enjoyed it.
One of the things I really enjoyed his,
there's a version of it on youtube,
if you see the version on youtube,
so many captured,
like one of his sets before the special was actually tape where it was like he
was on fire.
He was just like hitting every beat,
getting ready for the special,
you know,
and it was more loose and relaxed and the actual special itself,
I really enjoyed it better actually.
I thought you could see like how funny he really is when he's on,
I didn't know who he was and I saw him at the comedy store a while back.
Wow.
I was so blown away.
I Dunno.
Uh,
three,
four years ago.
Oh,
okay.
And I remember just watching him,
it was on tripping on Tuesdays or whatever they call it.
And I was just like,
what the fuck?
And I walked up to him,
I go,
Bro.
And I was incredible.
Ah,
thanks man.
Thank you.
Know,
it was very funny dude.
He's a powerful man.
He's proud when he's nailing it,
man.
He's powerful.
20 years of comedy.
Right?
And Matt,
that's my kind of comedy too.
It's a lot.
I love his kind of comedy.
It's just so ridiculous that when he had that issue,
like he had a bunch of arrests and all kinds of shit.
I was really bummed out because he's like one of my favorite guys to watch.
I'm like,
please don't spiral.
Don't spiral.
Keep it together,
man.
Yeah,
well he did.
Well,
you know,
only he knows,
but he did that special.
That was a big thing he did on Hbo.
Spike Lee directed it.
That was a big thing.
I think he's the funniest.
He makes me laugh the most.
Kills me when he's on,
you know,
but Stan hope makes me laugh hard too,
but in a totally different way.
Stan hope was like pointing shit out.
That is just ridiculous.
And then driving it through the fucking skull of America or as Kat Williams,
just being hilarious.
Just being,
I mean he has points,
he does make points,
but he's just,
he's all about being fucking hilarious.
Whether it's making fun of himself or making fun of,
you know,
someone else or everybody.
I just,
this is a great time for comedy,
man.
It's a great time to be a fan.
Yeah,
it really is.
It's a great time to be a comedian too,
cause there's so much stupid shit going on.
It's like every time you turn around there's some new fucking stupid thing.
It's just endless till you just do,
there's so many things to talk about.
If I followed sports boy really of material,
if you had like some,
uh,
some good NFL wife beating.
Yeah.
Terrible.
I don't know what the fuck is going on,
but it seems like every day you're trying,
it's been going on forever.
I think now it's just being more exposed.
I think that's what it is.
Huge League.
Huge number of guys.
Yeah.
What is their,
to get three or four dudes in the NFL,
how many?
I think there's 50 50 guys at Jamie would know how many guys?
50 guys at team.
What's that?
50 per team?
Yeah,
so 50 times 32 you're going to have three or four dudes in that ratio who are
going to step out.
Okay.
I'm not surprised.
There's no doubt about it,
right?
Yeah.
I mean that's a thousand something was at 1500 1500 dudes.
If 1500 dudes,
that's a pretty low average.
Actually,
if you only get a few wife beaters,
I wonder what would happen if you got 1500 cement workers?
15 I'd be a little higher.
Yeah,
that right now.
How about 1500 you know,
whatever.
Fill in the blank.
Yeah.
You know,
that's why when,
when everybody says,
you know,
all this guy got divorced,
he got fucked over women are cunts.
You,
that's all you ever hear about it.
But I love when I hear about people that get amicably separated.
Yeah.
Nobody hurts it.
He's,
there was a lady who got arrested who was on the walking dead.
She,
uh,
she was an actress.
Like she had a small part and the walking dead,
she sent Reisen like that fucking poison to people under her husband's name.
Like she tried to say that he was sending it and it was her,
she's doing like 20 fucking years in jail for that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Fucking terrifying it.
We'll take it to a whole nother level.
You kidding me?
And people,
I'm going to send poison and get you locked up in jail forever and laugh.
I'm going to set you up cause you don't want to be with me anymore or you
cheated on me or what?
You know,
you fucking wrecked my car.
Whatever the hell he did.
I don't know what he did.
I know a guy who was dating a girl got in a fight.
She,
um,
pulled,
he fell asleep,
he took a pill,
fall asleep on the plane.
She unzipped his pants and pulled out as junk,
let it sit there.
And he got in real trouble for that.
Well,
I'm like,
how did he ever get out?
Uh,
he had to go to court.
He had to hire a lawyer and go to court and everything.
In fact.
And uh,
yeah,
it was a,
it was a major end.
They were even thinking about having him.
He was going to maybe even have to register as a sex offender.
It became a real issue because the nightmare and the story goes on.
But I won't talk about it and the fuck.
Yeah.
Sounds crazy.
God.
Well that can happen because you know what,
man,
you don't know.
They can't scan your brain and say,
oh,
this guy's in a sex pervert.
He's just the guy that got caught up in a relationship with a crazy person.
But you know,
there's so,
there's so much power and accusing someone of something or it's setting someone
up.
There's so much power.
If,
if someone can do that,
male or female,
someone can send
anthrax in your name and get you busted.
Washed it off from the side.
Right.
Ah,
she was,
she's like,
what kind of a sick fuck caught though in those forensics guy come in and they
go and they started asking you a question.
Well,
let's go through this.
they have to do is get your DNA.
They,
there's so many people,
they leave DNA on envelopes.
They don't even realize it.
You're sweaty.
Fuck you licked that envelope.
Oh,
you licked it.
Congratulations.
You're arrested for the rest of your life.
The best people I know.
It's such a good guy.
He got wait a minute.
Accused besides you,
besides you in the workplace,
how you suddenly get hurt.
One of the,
one of the best people I know got accused of sexual harassment and got suspended
from his job for a year.
It was a government job.
So he hires a lawyer.
Did he really sexually harassed?
No,
no.
My short story is crazy.
The story was he said something,
he said something in an illusion to her dress that had relevant something else
and she goes,
I don't feel comfortable and ran out,
but she has a history of doing this to people.
So he hires a lawyer,
a woman.
So how you have to hire this woman?
My Buddy said they went,
they went and sat at a table and before it even got to any kind of trial or
anything,
they they,
they usually think about arbitration.
He started,
he said,
she started asking this woman some questions and you got to realize this woman
thought she could get away with a lie,
but all of a sudden she got into the ring.
She got in the ring with somebody who does this for a living with a lawyer who
does specializes in people who fraudulent claims are fraudulent claims.
So all of a sudden she started,
she started asking this woman questions that my friend hadn't even thought of
and he said,
dude,
it was the crate.
He eviscerated her until she finally said,
I don't feel comfortable.
I don't want to do this.
She went to jumbled their hands.
I don't feel good about,
I don't want to do this.
And she goes,
so do you want to drop the charges because you were maybe fabricating the
circumstances?
I don't.
Whatever,
whatever.
But I went away.
We went.
But it's still scary that someone could just do that to decide.
They decide they hate you.
Fuck yes.
Or they decide they love you.
You don't want to have anything to do with them.
Oh God.
Play misty for me.
All right.
Yeah,
and there's a lot of that out there,
man.
People are fucking nuts.
Male and female,
both sides.
That's why it's gross.
When anybody ever goes one way or the other.
I'm all for women's rights.
I'm all for men's rights.
There's some,
some women I don't like at all.
I'm just off men.
I don't want to be around ever for the rest of my life.
It doesn't matter what gender they are.
Like I don't give a fuck.
Right.
Should meant women get extra rights?
No.
Should they get equal rights?
Absolutely.
Everywhere.
Everyone.
Everyone should be treated evenly by law without a doubt.
But when you like when you're more geared up towards one side or the other,
like I can't get behind these men's rights dudes.
I can't.
So strange.
I tell,
look,
I think there's definitely some fucked up laws when it comes to alimony.
There's some fucked up laws when it comes to
child,
a child like custody laws and you know,
some people do like what you were talking about and what I was talking about.
Some people make fraudulent claims about their children and they'll do it and
they'll set a guy up just so that they can get total custody.
They're going to war,
right?
So if they'll lie about a mean,
someone who had send Reisen is not above lying about what the husband did to the
children.
You know,
there's a lot of crazy shit that goes on,
but it's a human issue more than it's a male woman.
Sure.
There's some fucked up laws for sure.
I was going to say if you took 1500 women,
I wonder how many actually have lashed out and hit their husbands.
Even in the ray rice video.
I believe she had.
She hits him by,
but yeah,
she hit him.
But when you're supposed to do is hold on to them unless you see the same size.
Unless you're fighting Ronda Rousey,
you better throw some fucking bombs or you better be ready to tap out.
You get it.
I hope she doesn't break your shit off and stuff it up your ass.
No doubt she will,
but otherwise just grab a hold of him.
Don't hit.
It's just,
and if you really are fighting a chick that you're living with a chick who is
prone to violence and can probably kick your ass,
break up with her.
She's too scary.
It's too scary.
I dated a girl who used to get very physically abusive.
Ooh,
that's scary.
Called her dumb once she was drunk.
I didn't know she was drunk.
One of the drunks where you don't know they're drunk and she like,
they just act normal and it just kind of calling.
I called her dumb,
a wildcard dumb,
can't remember,
but it was just one of many things.
I called her.
She swung a boot at me so hard at so hard.
She was so strong.
I ducked,
I ducked in it and I had one of those sliding closet and it just,
just went right through that cloud sliding glass.
Just good goose.
Just a hole in it.
Whoa.
I was like,
what is going on here man?
I mean it was nuts.
It was fuck her after that.
Sure it did.
Yeah.
I,
he held her down and I said,
hey,
calm down,
calm down.
And then we fucked.
Well that's the best part of that kind of relationship that that was fun for a
year until I had to figure out a way to meet victor.
Yeah.
Okay,
let's not talk her.
I know who that is.
Um,
you know,
the violent part in the making up part of a lot of times that's like what they
grew up with,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
Or they run out of,
I think a lot of times violence is an offshoot of running out of other
ammunition.
So you're not,
you can't think of something witty to say.
You can't really think of a comeback.
You don't even know what to do.
I think a lot of times it's almost like,
um,
uh,
you regress immediately.
You just strike,
you just strike because children,
when they don't have the language,
they'll hit.
I dated a girl when I was in high school and we broke up and she was dating this
dude and uh,
she used to,
we used to work at the same place and when I went to visit her once,
I was talking to her and she was telling me she was crying.
Tell me about this guy that she's dating that beats her.
He hits her and I was like,
oh my God.
Like I couldn't believe it.
And then she goes,
you know,
what's really fucked up?
Like it.
I couldn't finish that sentence for you.
I go,
you like it?
Yeah.
And she goes,
yeah,
I like it.
I don't know why I like it when he hits me.
I go,
you like it when he hits you?
Yeah.
I go like,
do you want him to keep hitting you?
She's like,
no,
I'm just fucked up.
And I go,
whoa.
I go,
you mean he like he broke her window.
He punched through her window because she's important enough.
She's important enough to elicit and insane response.
So she feels valued.
Well,
I was,
it was fascinating to me because we were both really young at the time.
I think I was probably,
shit,
I couldn't have been more than like 17 or 18 and she was probably like the same.
She was like 17 I was 18 I think.
Something like that.
So when she was telling me this,
I was like,
what?
Like you liked it when this guy hits you?
It's strange.
I cook.
Might've been 19,
18 [inaudible] neighborhood.
You know,
we're just at a high,
I just had a high school,
you know,
she had graduated so she had to be 18,
so it was,
um,
it was just bizarre conversation.
I was like,
you can't let people hit you.
Look at how many people wore red rice,
how many women were Ray Rice's Jersey and number at the next game because they
want that violent dick.
I Dunno,
but they were all in solidarity.
I thought that was amazing.
Yeah.
This,
there's a weird thing.
It's weird thing when people just decide to fucking jump on board with the
assholes and wife.
His wife,
his wife came out and was very public about defending him.
Yeah.
Well,
hey,
um,
if she complicated,
half are fucking brain knocked in.
Who knows where her judgements at?
Dude,
she got Kod and bounced her head off the pole.
She could have easily Baghdad easily been Daniel easily been dead.
The idea that he hit her like that and being me,
I don't know.
Most of the way he dragged her out and didn't really tend to her call it kind
of,
that was what was,
I thought it was so impersonal.
It's strange.
Like he just like if he had,
if he had knocked her out and grabbed her and be like,
oh my God,
Oh my God.
Like I just,
I,
I reacted or whatever.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm a violent guy.
I played football but to,
to kind of almost look at her and kind of move her with his foot and it was just
like,
whoa.
Wow.
You,
you are,
that's,
that's bad news.
Fucked up.
That's the most fucked up.
Well,
no,
the most fucked up is the impact.
The Punch.
That's the second most fucked up thing is how he treated her like,
bitch,
get the fuck up.
You know,
just try.
It wasn't until someone showed up and people kind of freaking out that it
became,
you know,
something that,
by the way,
that it too,
there are cameras in elevators.
I don't know if you know that in 2000 and nobody was thinking that man.
All he was thinking was she's,
she ain't hitting me.
You know,
he's going to hit her back.
There's,
I was on a plane once with Michael Irvin and Michael Irvin.
We were,
it's a long ass flight.
We're going to Australia just randomly happen to be on the plane with me.
And he's a good dude.
He's always at the UFC.
He's a great guy and a great athlete.
And we're talking and he was talking about this foundation that he has.
We works with,
uh,
a lot of,
young kids,
teaches them how to harness their anger.
And what he explained,
he was explaining this to me on the flight that when grow up in
bad neighborhoods with there,
there's violence in the house and then the mothers under stress all the time.
It changes like the reaction that the boy has to violence when he gets outside,
it changes his reaction to stress.
It makes him like ultra impulsive,
makes them like an inclined towards violence.
And he was talking about how you literally have to figure out how to rewire your
brain.
You know,
and he was talking for personal experience and he was talking about how you have
to figure out how to rewire your brain in a positive way,
you know?
And that it's very important to recognize that these kids are coming out of the
gate with the,
the amount of control that you expect out of a reasonable adult.
They don't have that amount.
They have less.
And one of the reasons why they have less as the shit they were exposed to when
they were in the fucking Wu man.
I mean,
it's like it's beyond them.
Yeah.
You know,
and I think that's the case with a lot of people.
I've wondered if that's the case with myself and I don't think I was exposed to
too much stress in the womb,
but I was exposed to a lot of violence when I was young.
I remember a lot of luck,
fucking crazy shit in my house and my dad's house after my mom moved out because
my dad used to beat my mom.
I remember.
I remember
crazy stuff.
That's dude,
you don't get over that.
I mean that's the shapes you,
I mean,
I remember,
I remember how you were when you were younger because the world was a dangerous
place,
man.
You kept things at an arm's length.
You are always ready to go.
Always.
Like you just were always like,
who's that guy?
I don't know that guy.
You gotta be careful.
Okay.
Why is that guy talking to us right now?
I remember you were always paranoid that with controlling of the environment,
you know,
and then you started to calm down.
I think we'd helped a lot.
That helped a lot.
You know?
And you've got to hold her,
but I'm,
when you were younger you were not,
you trusted me.
And maybe one or two other people was also,
it was coming straight off of competitive fighting.
She like most of my formative years,
like from 15 to 21 so I go into Columbus.
What happened when you were in it happened that shit.
All that shit.
She'll say when you have,
when you have a dad like you did.
I'm sorry man.
That's not how kids aren't supposed to see that or they are,
yeah.
Well,
you know,
we took a long time.
We spent all their time trying to shelter and protect our children.
I wonder if that's the best thing sometimes too.
I'm a dude out of the gate.
I trusted nobody can.
I remember
being five years old and uh,
thinking people who are retarded.
I remember clearly like seeing people argue over shit when I was like five years
old.
Go on these fucking dummies.
Jeez.
Climber being in Lebanon during the war.
And how old are you?
I was a,
I'll tell I'll,
do you want him even better?
I was fifth,
sixth,
fourth,
fifth and sixth grade I think.
Or even younger.
So is that 10?
I was,
uh,
probably from the age of Eight,
nine,
10 in the war.
Uh,
and and seeing a hearing machine,
guns having to sleep on the floor,
having to sleep in the basement,
seeing planes bomb,
you know,
shooting missiles and Bama gas station when you're like,
Hey dad,
how many more years?
This shit,
we've got to deal
with my bag and put fuck back then.
At one point my dad couldn't get back in.
We had to be evacuated to Greece,
but that feeling that,
that feeling of helplessness as a boy,
machine guns,
men in uniforms,
just me,
my mom and my sister,
that kind of stuff.
That stuff makes you feel,
you never forget that stuff.
Don't you think that that also sort of imparted that nomadic thing that you have
going on where you could like live anywhere?
Fuck.
Pull up right now.
Like Brian is one of the only dudes that I know where I could say,
hey man,
I got a place in New Mexico.
You want to move there with me?
Yeah.
Okay.
If you didn't have a family,
no problem healing,
you would pull up your shit and go anywhere.
You don't.
You make it flash at all.
I'd be like,
what do you need to bring my clothes?
Let's go.
Let's get outta here.
You don't.
I remember when you didn't have a door knob.
He didn't have a fucking door knob.
You know,
some people say,
oh you God keeps his door open all the time.
He's never,
his door's never locked.
No,
no,
no.
He didn't have a fucking door.
Nothing.
You could still go over his house and I would go with Bro.
You don't have a door knob like are going to open.
I can get on my knees and I can look through your fucking door hole.
How about Adventist?
When the woman was cooking breakfast,
cooking.
Do you got it going on honey?
She's making a meal at my stove.
The cops where you want to cuss charges?
I was like no homeless person that's walked in.
I was like [inaudible] place.
Yeah,
that was the same place.
We didn't have a door knob.
Yep.
He was in Venice.
Venice.
Completely ridiculous.
What are you gonna Steal my TV?
I don't care.
Yeah,
you would just,
you could always abandoned shit.
Why did I have are,
but do you,
do you think that's why like you don't appreciate Nice Shit.
Like you don't even appreciate it.
Like a nice car.
Like you know,
you make good money.
You can get like one of those sweet new Cadillacs or something like that.
And a Tesla.
I want it.
Ooh,
look,
comfy to drive around.
I just,
I've always had a sense of guilt,
partially because I grew up in countries where people had nothing.
I remember seeing like somebody with leprosy and no foot in,
in Yemen,
uh,
going through the marketplaces and when you're a white kid and,
and the math falls in your favor for no fucking reason.
You,
you don't think that you're God's favorite.
You just as a kid,
I couldn't navigate or understand why I saw like kids coming up to a starving in
India and Pakistan asking for food [inaudible] and I had everything.
That doesn't make sense.
That doesn't make you feel good as a kid.
Especially not someone like me.
I had the imagination or whatever it was to kind of go,
I got lucky because the math fell in my favor.
I did zero to deserve this and that.
That creates two things.
Guilt and shame,
I think.
Um,
and I never lost that.
I never lost that.
I still feel that way.
That's fascinating.
I hate having people come work at my house.
Like,
if,
if they're doing work in my house and I go out of my way to make sure that they,
you know,
feel like I'm the same as they are,
I don't like,
I'd be terrible.
It'd be a terrible king.
I feel.
I find it very uncomfortable.
Uh,
all that stuff anyway.
Yeah,
no,
I hear Ya.
That might be why my father laughed at me one time.
He came to visit me and my father grew up poor and he was laughing.
He goes,
what's with this car?
I was driving some terrible forward and it was really dirty.
And he's like,
you know,
I can afford to buy you a Lexus
if you wanted.
Would you want one of those?
And I was like,
no,
I never thought of that.
First of all,
I don't want somebody else getting it for me.
Second of all,
it just didn't,
it wouldn't make an impact in my life.
And I respect though,
like Brendan Brennan shop grew up with not a lot of money,
so nice things to him.
Nice clothes,
nice car.
They mean a lot.
They mean they,
they,
they remind him that he's not what he used to be.
Yeah,
man.
So I've always respected the idea of limited materialism.
I understand where it comes from.
I also think it depends on what you're turned on by.
I'm wearing says more interested in that.
You know,
somebody said this woman wrote this book,
said I had all these experiences.
She went to study for work with the KGB as an interpreter and then went to the
Antarctic and then went to India and she said I was doing nothing.
I had all these experiences but my brain wasn't changing.
I needed to figure out how to change my mind.
She had failed math in high school,
but she was looking,
she was in the military and she was watching all these,
uh,
these engineers solve problems in this beautiful way,
but it looked like hieroglyphics and she goes,
wait a minute,
if I can learn how to do this,
then I'll change the way my brain works.
And she talks about it a lot and she became a professor of engineering.
But you know that I think I'm more interested maybe,
maybe.
It depends on what you're more turned it on by.
I'm really fascinated with changing who I am in a way.
Maybe the way I put he tried to be,
uh,
just just continue to be as original and as creative as I can be.
That's all.
That's my thing.
And you can't have a tussle in that.
I can,
I want to get a test last.
I think I'm going to,
I'm waiting for my Passat,
my turbo diesel Passat lease to run out.
This is just devil's advocate.
Yeah.
But people that make good money and then don't buy nice things.
What is the fucking point of making good money?
Someone who is poor who looks at you.
We'd be like,
hey dummy,
you,
you know,
you're like,
part of,
you know,
we've talked about this yesterday,
the 1% of the world of the world,
more than $34,000 a year.
It's just nuts.
That's the world.
I know how lucky I am.
Do you know how crazy that is?
Yeah.
And I buy nice things.
I mean I have a nice house and all that and I'm not,
believe me,
I'm not like some smart sign.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But what I'm saying is get a Tesla.
That's what you're saying.
What I'm saying is people that like make a ton of money and then don't buy nice
things.
There's one that's one look like,
hey man,
you know,
you,
you're the guy that has the opportunity to make a bunch of money,
buy nice things,
but then there's the other point of view.
It's like,
okay,
well what are,
you know you'd hear about Warren Buffett lives in a regular neighborhood and
he's got a fucking $100 billion.
Um,
yeah,
because you don't form of affectation.
Right.
If he's going to live in a regular neighborhood,
how about you give away 8 billion?
Yeah.
You ain't even going to use it.
Yes.
Just sitting there and you're 90 correct.
And I'm sure there's a lot of like philanthropic adventures that he invests
money in.
I'm sure he spends a lot of money on other things,
but I'm saying like what level do you think you're supposed to give back?
Like,
what are you supposed to give to charity?
Are you supposed to be nice to your fellow humans or the other?
I've been writing about the idea that,
you know,
this,
this idea that I've not anything bad enough to go to hell,
but I feel like I have not even good enough to go to.
I'm definitely not sitting anywhere close to mother Theresa if she's in heaven.
You know,
I just feel like there's a lot more evident held over your head.
In other words.
In other words,
there's a lot more I could be doing to give to charity.
Like kind of literary.
Yes,
I'm being literary,
I'm being,
I'm being deep,
I'm being spiritual.
But I do feel like I should be given more in some ways the charity.
But then I think to myself,
I'm doing exactly what I was putting on the earth to do,
which is make people laugh.
And that takes a lot of work in that stop right there.
Isn't that just justifying like the uncomfortable nature of that discussion?
Maybe I'm just fucking awesome and I'm here to be awesome.
And again,
I snips rather be an awesome cause I spend a lot of money on wine and yeah,
but that's not what you were saying.
You were saying like,
I should I feel like should I give more to charity and what does that mean?
Okay.
First of all,
here's the difference.
Here's the,
here's how you delineate.
So if I could give to charity and we can,
there's a lot of different definitions.
Is,
is charity going back to what we were talking about,
his charity,
what people need or do they need inspiration?
So how do you create inspiration?
So giving,
giving money to survive or I dunno,
why is it an or?
I'm just wondering if I could do,
if I could make a big difference that there's,
there's a school in Haiti or something I'm sure could use some money.
Right,
right.
Okay.
All right.
I could give to that school.
Um,
and I do,
I do have charities I give to give to doctors without borders.
I give to operation smile.
Uh,
that's at different things.
I got my own individual thing.
People,
people who have a hard time when they give charity.
And they find out how much money goes to administrative costs.
Fucking drives me crazy fucking,
I think the United way.
What was it?
What'd they say?
Out of a dollar or a penny actually goes to the charity.
The rest of his run,
the whole fucking thing.
It's a whole bureaucracy.
They got to run,
but to business it drives me crazy.
It drives me crazy.
One penny does go to the starving kids will go fuck yourself because I want my
number is pull up the number of find out which organization was it?
United way.
See how much I'm going to get actually goes,
I believe it's a penny.
I believe it's a,
it's a,
it's a hundred I'm going to get crazy and say it's 20 cents.
20 cents out of a dollar.
Okay.
You think it's really a penny used to be,
give it a special on and say it's 47 40 cents.
I don't think it's that high.
I bet it's less than 40 cents to huge company.
Okay.
I say 20 you say one?
Brian says 40 is it 47.
Oh,
you're saying for you?
So I'll be like the Internet that we had get at the answers to all these
instantly when he's Google it though sometimes not so much.
Sometimes not.
Sometimes shit gets a little confabulated.
There are,
there are really good charities out there that make a difference.
Well,
the thing is,
here's the question,
should someone running a charity make a salary?
Of course they should.
Yes.
But should they make a salary relative to what people make in America or the
third world country where they're aiding?
That's when shit gets weird because if it's the third world country that they're
eating,
well,
they're going to be bitter as shit.
Yeah.
They're working their whole life way and they can't even fucking put a roof over
their head and feed themselves normally.
So it should be like an American salary,
I would imagine.
But if it's an American salary for a professional,
like what is that?
Is it a hundred grand's at 50 grand is at 35 grand?
What's the answer?
Okay.
United way.
Uh,
well this is United way up to Pika.
So I'm just,
I'm guessing this is a good example of what United.
Okay.
I guess different local Bud withholds 20% with holds.
What do you mean with holds 20% of the,
of what you give of what you give.
Yeah.
Um,
can you list so they only take,
so today when a 22% 22% okay.
I just googled what percentage where it is United way charity go right here.
Okay.
United Way with holds 22% from 2012 designation designations.
Yeah.
I think they got exposed and they start,
they,
they made a change because they had,
they ran a special a long time ago about,
okay,
here it is worldwide United way claimed combined administrative and fundraising
expenses in 2011 of 17% meaning that they spend approximately 17 cents for every
dollar donated on organizational costs,
but the other 83 cents go directly towards community projects.
That's awesome.
That's pretty good.
Yeah.
So United way's not a good example.
They used to be,
there was,
the state did a whole Exposito on them and,
and it was shocking.
I think they changed w maybe we can't Google that.
What percentage of money goes to charity?
Let's,
let's just Google that.
Have money.
Like what's the worst?
Well,
we think the worst,
but I ain't,
that's really good.
I mean,
if they can 17% it wasn't like the Jimmy Lewis thing.
A brutal one.
I don't know.
The muscular dystrophy,
I don't know about that.
Okay.
What percentage of,
what's Google that,
what is,
what was that telephone called?
A Jerry Lewis Telethon.
Jerry Lewis
charity
telephone.
Okay.
Guess this,
what do you guess?
What percentage?
Okay.
I would say,
I don't know.
I would say I would,
high percentage,
I would say 80% goes to the kids.
America's 50th worth chair.
Worst charities rake in nearly 1 billion for corporate fundraising.
There you go.
Wow.
Was may not necessarily be bad if they,
if they motivate people to get even more money,
but yeah.
Well look,
there's a certain amount of money that they would never get right if it wasn't
for those things.
Like someone was talking about the ice bucket challenge,
the ice bucket challenge as stupid as fuck,
but three's the ridiculous amount of money and most people were doing it.
They're not,
they're not even donating money and just throwing water on their head.
But the amount of people that have done,
it's pretty substantial.
Yeah.
It's millions,
millions of dollars.
Much more than they had last year.
Als Sucks.
I'm sure.
I'm sure you know,
they don't even think that Lou Gehrig had Lou Gehrig's disease.
And that's strange.
Why?
Cause he just got hit in the head.
Yeah,
I think it's trauma related.
He was k out so many times while playing baseball,
sliding into people and shit,
playing hard baseball played football,
I believe.
Yeah.
Look at this.
Joe Did it.
Worst charities ranked by money blown on.
So this thing costs number one,
kid's wish network total raised a one point 127 million paid 109 million.
So 2.5
well no.
The page of solicitors and houseless spent on direct cache solicitors would,
that means like advertising,
right?
Is that what that means?
What is paid to solicitors mean?
Well,
percentage spent on direct cash aid looks like 2.5% 0.9% 10.8 you used to work
for a bank.
You can't figure this shit out.
No.
Well,
what does solicitors mean?
What does solicitors,
what's the difference?
The definition of solicitor.
I would imagine that people that are paying that are,
that are selling,
that are somehow going out there and raising the money.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So this is paid to the like the spent on getting the money.
So lawyers,
no people who I'd go out and actually raise the funds.
Well,
solicitors or legal practitioner,
this is the actual definition.
Solicitor is a legal practitioner.
Tourists traditionally deals with any legal matter in court.
In some jurisdictions.
The solicitation also mean someone who sells me solicitating prostitute
listeners or people that are the actual fund raisers though in this context.
But,
but isn't that someone who was buying?
No,
it's somebody who who's doing the fund raising to selling.
They're,
they're essentially going out there.
I believe.
What happens if you solicit a prostitute though?
Doesn't that mean you're trying to pay for the prostitutes?
So that's the solicitor,
right?
So no solicitation,
no snow trying to sell me anything around here.
The kids,
kids wish network has five employees.
It's getting paid,
it's paying them,
and then they're only paying 2.5%
to the actual direct cash aid for this.
So only 2.5% of their money,
right?
Percentage spent on direct cash a day.
2.5% that's insane.
What's the other 1.9% for the cancer fund of America?
That's insane.
Less than 1% children's with found that he,
these are all like off on the other charities and they're all scams.
That's so dirty.
American breast cancer foundation,
not associate.
Well,
I find a charitable foundation.
That one.
Look at that one.
And you need to police officers' Union of police associates.
Look at that.
Less than half of a half of a percent.
Yeah,
there,
there.
That's a scam,
man.
Oh wait,
there's one that's 0% look at this operation.
Look Out National Center for Missing Youth.
0%
wow,
that's insane.
But how's that work?
It says 19.6 million in 16.0 you know what that is?
That's like rent and shit operation.
Look at that.
So the 15 million is paid to out to people.
The rest is bills.
Fuck man.
I was not to,
we live in a dirty world.
The world is dirty veterans fund.
That's so creepy that there's charities that are that far off.
Less than a percent committee for missing children.
We thought what did I guess?
I guess 20 you guessed one.
Yeah,
there you go.
And there's some that are a half of a one.
There you go.
That's why.
That's why he got to be careful what charities you give to and I think United
way they did this thing and they were like,
how much of your money's actually going there?
Back in the day,
I think it was United.
How about the charity when they're at the airport and they have the open bucket?
Oh forget and they want cash.
I don't know if you are a plastic hole and an open bucket and around the bucket
is photographs of kids.
And it's like some thing and they have a clipboard.
I don't know who you are.
Sorry.
Yeah.
This lady came up to me at the airport once and she was super aggressive about
it and I said,
get the fuck out of here with that scam.
She goes,
fuck you mother fucker.
I go,
that's what I was hoping for.
that's what I want to hear.
I go,
you're in charge.
You're involved in a charitable organization,
right.
She's like,
fuck you bitch.
I go,
you're involved in a charitable organization.
You're not going to dip into that and take while you're a reputable person.
Fuck you bitch.
There you go.
She got to hit me.
It was pretty close.
She has definitely hit me.
It's so great.
I was tired.
I was tired,
man.
I just landed,
you know,
working and then someone like,
she was aggressive about it too.
It was like,
she was like,
you know,
sir,
would you please donate to help you don't Bubba Bubba,
bubba.
I'm looking at her and I'm like,
I smell danger all over you.
You don't seem like a charitable person,
but you could just show up with like a clipboard and a bucket and you know some
logo on the bucket and you get people to give you cash you to leave you the fuck
alone.
Well that actually if you're aggressive cut down on that cause they should hide.
Christmas used to always come up to you at airports.
Yeah,
but they're Wackos.
You look at them and you're like,
what's what you're heck?
I'd tongue poke and the fuck out of here.
I'm not giving you any money.
You're crazy.
You're not wearing sandals and you're a man.
Like what are you doing?
You're,
you're not even like a surfer and a saffron robe thing is a mess.
You smell weird.
Get Out,
get out.
You smell like curry run.
Your American would be like,
ew,
I don't want to be near you and I don't want to give you any money to support
this thing that you're doing.
And they would sell you a book.
Fuck Outta here.
What your book's about.
Glad Anita get book.
It depends on,
I would love to buy the Bhagavad Gita.
Love to,
but not from some dirty hippie.
I'm going to go to a nice store was a nice person who sells books.
They could tell me about it.
You know,
there's some beautiful fucking grass.
You don't see them anymore.
Like Hari Krishna is like the Internet.
Yeah.
And that smoke them out.
They're like,
what are we doing?
Everybody thinks we're stupid.
Even Scientologists make fun of them.
Hari Krishna is the bottom end of the cult pole.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
Everybody goofs on them.
Dunkin could do the whole chant.
Vegetarians was he of Hari Krishna?
No,
but he just,
he's really like involved in studying religions and study them his whole life.
He can do long Buddhist chants,
but Long Hari Krishna Chang.
Yeah.
He does all that shit.
He can do it like,
and it sounds like,
like one of those monks and those hollow echoing at monastery so much about Zen
Buddhism and Buddhism.
And I've had every book I could get my hands on on Buddhism.
I was just
like,
this is the answer.
You know?
Maybe it is,
but I just somehow got too busy.
I don't think there's any answer.
Yeah,
because in the end everybody dies.
That's for dash no answer.
This is what it is.
How much are you enjoying this and how much are you enjoying being around others
who are enjoying it and helping each other out and having a good time cause
other than that,
what,
what else is there?
Is there a deep meaning?
If everything's temporary,
it doesn't seem like it could be.
It seems like you're a part of some sort of weird evolutionary process that will
go on as long as life is allowed to exist on this planet,
which is very finite.
The planet itself only has like 1.6 billion years of life left.
Do you think though that you know that if it goes more than that the sun's gonna
burst sizing son runs out of juice,
but do you think that there is some,
there is a either movement toward each other or a movement towards something or
do you think it's all random and it's hard question,
who the fuck?
No,
fuck no one knows.
I mean it might.
It might not be.
What about human progress?
Do you think we've been progressing?
Yes.
Yeah.
We're tough when there's steps back.
Like when we talk about like people being PC and all that stuff.
I think it's terrible,
but it's way better than being racist.
It's way better than the PC shit is way better than segregated where the blacks
have to sit in the back of the bus.
He not,
the keys are different water cooler this way better.
Yeah.
So that to me is clear example.
But then there's also drones and spying and crazy shit and people are still
getting locked up near challenge,
crazy drug laws.
And then there's private prisons as corporate interests and this fucking,
this,
this Goldman Sachs thing that came out.
Well,
the,
the tapes that are now being released of the Fed in coercion with Goldman Sachs.
I mean all the different shit that's going on.
We,
you see that still,
it's still corruption.
There's still evil is still just misdirected energy.
Incorrect patterns of behavior that have led to people to what to operate in
this same type of momentum that the,
the fucking knucklehead traders before them have done.
And the fucking military industrial complex guys from the 60s did.
It's all the same kind of,
that energy's hasn't been flushed out of the system yet,
but it seems like it's slowly getting pushed into a corner or at least it's hard
to hide.
She would,
the fuck is going on in Hong Kong.
Yeah,
Dude.
Brian,
pull up the photos.
There's a drone video of the protest and Hong Kong.
Holy Shit.
It's an island.
A 7 million that actually want our,
we want to be able to choose who governs them.
Can you imagine that?
There's a lot of fucking people I know a lot of PE,
they're also bordered.
There's also 1.3 billion people on,
on their border and uh,
they don't feel,
they don't want to be part of China.
The mainland.
Well,
they used to not be until fairly recently.
It used to be controlled by the United Kingdom.
Right,
right.
Look at this fucking video though.
There's going to freak you out because they're flying over.
They,
by the way,
it's amazing that they can do that now.
You could just like a regular person can get a drone.
Crazy.
When we did that Scifi show,
dude,
I put on these goggles,
like these VR goggles and they put a camera on this drone and then flew the
drone over the tree tops and I was like watching from the drones perspective,
I was like,
oh my,
we couldn't put it in the episode because we just didn't have enough time.
But I was like,
I'm flying.
It was amazing of sick.
That's an amazing,
that's a camera to an eagle.
But I'm telling you at felt like I was flying.
Like when I had these Vr VR goggles on.
Wow.
I had VR goggles on.
This thing is flying through trees and stuff and you're,
you're watching like,
whoa,
how much would that cost to buy?
I want one,
probably a lot.
And they don't go very far.
Like after a mile,
it doesn't transmit like the wine,
the signal,
whatever type of signal.
Look at this.
This is the,
uh,
the crowd.
And this is a them filming this by drone.
Unbelievable.
Do their tea.
They've shut down the city.
This is incredible.
Look at that.
Ooh,
that's a million people,
right?
At least,
I don't know.
I don't know if it walks like,
I think there are 7 million.
That's like 300 people,
Bro.
Crazy.
That's like a Nick's comedy.
Stop Pact.
That's second Joe Rogan content.
Look how many fucking people.
It's like ants on rice noodle and what year were would they United Kingdom.
It was until like the night thing
when the lease ran out in um,
gosh,
19 and nine 2000 2001 1997 what was it?
I think it was 97 maybe [inaudible] was it later?
They're bracing both sides.
Brace for Wednesday.
Show down.
Oh fuck.
Are they going to go world war three in Hong Kong too?
I don't think.
Nobody wants that.
They don't want the People's Liberation Army.
And the,
the,
you know,
coming into was Liberation Army and the people that call and think,
yeah,
that's what they Chinese,
I think that's what the Chinese call their army.
But they don't want the,
they don't want the Chinese military to come in and get unpleasant,
that's for damn sure.
So they're asking for the,
the,
the what I believe his name,
they call him the chairman.
The person that was put in power by China to step down and they want elections
to vote in their own.
Um,
in China is saying,
hey,
we're kind of running your country,
um,
you know,
for considered a country or is it considered considered
province and part of China,
mainland China.
And,
um,
I think that for the longest time,
remember that Hong Kong was the sort of the financial capital of that part of
the world.
But Shanghai now has taken over and a lot of other cities have taken over as
the,
they're richer.
Uh,
and,
and so it's a,
it's a complicated thing.
It's a lot of my mainland Chinese come in and vacation in Hong Kong.
Um,
so they're pretty dependent on each other.
Look at this photo of his kid shining his fucking flashlights.
They're all shined the light from
their cell phones.
It's really creepy.
It's on USA Today,
USA.
Today's coverage.
It's one of the larger photographs.
There's humility,
there's millions of kids,
and they all decided to turn their cell phone lights on and they're holding them
up in solidarity.
And it's kind of symbolic.
Well,
China also,
apparently the government of China is worried,
is really worried that if,
if they're,
if they don't,
if they don't handle this properly,
there are a lot of cities in China that could do the same thing and asking for
changes in how the country is governed.
So China's being very,
very cautious about how they treat this particular approach as they could fuck
this up.
Everything.
Yes.
Because if,
if it gets too successful,
if it's not,
there are a lot of things that fucking picture and there's a lot of unrest in
China.
Not did not just Hong Kong.
Well,
when did Hong Kong become a part of China?
I think it was during the opium trade,
wasn't it?
When we sold it,
sold it back to him and 97 and,
and it,
it was annexed by Shovan was annexed by the British,
I think a hundred years before that.
So it hasn't even been 20 years.
Right.
So they're just still trying to work it out.
I mean,
think about 20 years ago,
wasn't that like Clinton days?
Yeah.
97 those Clinton,
right?
Yeah.
97 Clinton was president.
And imagine that like if Clinton like leaves and then also trying to take over
the U S and we're like,
what?
Yeah,
like that's kind of the same sort of thing.
If they were under rule of the United Kingdom,
that's really similar to like the being America or Canada.
Absolutely.
It is really hard for the,
for,
and also remember in Hong Kong they speak Cantonese,
they don't speak Mandarin.
Most of mainland China is mostly a mandarin and they speak a very different
language.
In Hong Kong they speak mostly Mo,
they do speak mandarin,
but they also mainly speak Cantonese.
Wow.
Very different form of trans.
And it was a capitalist system,
a very wealthy area.
And the big fear was that when the politburo in China took over,
that they would impose communists,
you know,
market laws and things like that.
But I think they kind of left them alone for a while and then,
and now Hong Kong's economy is very tied up with mainland China's economy.
What a mess.
It's just weird when you see a situation like that where you know something's
going to happen and we're watching it from afar,
from way the fuck over here in California.
And we were like,
what is going to happen over there?
Well the question is is trying to going to allow them to behave like a separate
and independent province cause they,
they are not according to China and a Chinese law.
That's the issue.
So then what do you do?
What do you do?
Well.
Then you got to realize that the people in the military themselves,
other than the few people that are running it,
there's going to be a certain point in time where if,
if there's riots everywhere,
if the entire country goes topsy turvy over this,
if they all start emulating what's going on in Hong Kong,
there's a not enough soldiers to cover them all because there's a billion God
damn people and B,
it would be soldiers turned their guns on their own people.
Yeah.
These are regular folks just like the soldiers in America.
I mean it's one of the the weirdest things about people that don't want to
support the troops.
Like the idea that,
you know,
I don't support war so I don't want to support the troops.
Troops are just people and they might be the only thing and their love of
regular people might be the only thing that protects a really tie radical
government from turning their guns on the people themselves because they can't
do that.
If the people holding the guns are fuse somewhere down the chain.
If we where they say no,
they say no at general lost the election that Thomas Jefferson,
because he had a standing army and one of the things that you know,
the founding fathers warn against was a standing army.
Why?
Because a standing arbit can be hijacked by a charismatic,
a dictator,
and then they can,
they can stage a coup.
So that was always,
that was all,
it didn't sit well for a long time with Americans,
especially with the way this country was founded on the idea of a standing army
had always been abused.
Exactly what you're saying.
And we feel it's okay to go after someone if they have their own army,
like the Waco Guy.
I like the Waco Guy,
David Koresh.
He got very little sympathy in this country even though they essentially went in
and fire bomb these people killed kids,
shot people down.
There was fucking very clear images of Sherman tanks blowing fire into these
fucking buildings.
But we knew they had guns.
Yeah.
That's the only thing we knew.
We knew that we heard the fuck kids.
That was the thing.
Right.
But by the way,
I was a room.
That is exactly what I would say if I was going to fucking run some tanks into
some dude's house,
that guys,
and they're fucking kids.
We've got to,
we've got to go kill those kids.
And it was ATF anyway.
It was ATF is also,
you know,
basically about the fact that he had all this sort of a weapon.
Right.
And Arsenal.
But think about the ultimate irony.
We're going to save those kids by killing them all.
Yeah.
I mean they killed everybody.
I think they let some kids out at one point in time.
Yeah.
Some of them got out,
but a lot of them got burned and it was terrible.
There's a documentary about it that was kind of jaw dropping.
Well the documentary was highlighting the use of force and that was like one of
the first times where we saw like real military force being used on Tamil
civilians and,
and,
and the good news is that you sh,
you know,
a lot of people,
there was a documentary made out of it and a lot of people were pretty outraged
by it.
But yeah,
maybe not enough.
Hicks had a whole bid on it,
picks out a whole bid on it.
It was,
uh,
it was pretty fucking crazy.
It was just,
most people didn't see it because there was no fucking internet back then.
It wasn't like today.
If they did some Waco Shit today and we saw them driving over buildings and
blowing fire into these buildings,
pull up the video of Waco,
pull up the video.
What do you do when you checking your Facebook?
You Fuck,
look at those.
Look at that.
Look at what happened with Ferguson that this black kid who was shot.
I mean,
that whole town went crazy.
Things are different now.
It's different.
It's not that easy to just get away with shit anymore.
I also think though,
like I was thinking about Russia and how outdated they're calling the
ruble,
the currency,
the rubble now because it's just like,
it's just not worth anything.
It's a one copy.
It's very clever.
Play Underwood.
But it's a,
it's a one crop economy.
So Russia,
the motto is basically might makes right all the guys with guns control
everything.
Guess what?
So now you got,
you got commodities,
you've got oil that you export and I get some weaponry.
This is crazy.
This was in the 1990s.
This is a God damn tank tearing apart a house.
Yup.
This is a tank in America going into this quote unquote cult.
And because they had gotten into a firefight with these people because the ATF
shot at them,
the ATF,
they were like on the roofs and shit.
It's a really crazy documentary.
And one of the guys,
the ATF guy inside was shooting out the door at eight
people outside and they were making,
they were blasting,
um,
I guess music and stuff to make them crazy and noise.
What did they do that with these guys too?
Yeah.
That's a common tactic.
Why is the music that I was seeing if that was the music,
I hope that's not,
to me it is.
It
is that really,
it's the music that goes with the video.
Better get us pulled up youtube.
That's what that music is.
This is ridiculous.
I mean to see tanks being used on civilians,
helicopters and shit.
Oh Damn.
Okay.
But then if you look at it from the other hand,
like this is bizarre.
Nanos Jesus,
how fast that thing as you look at it from the other side,
if you've got a group of people that are in this house and they're shooting at
federal agents,
what do you do?
Do you do this?
Do you do this
wait amount?
Do you wait from stars on fire?
That's what you don't do that.
You definitely know when kids are in there.
So what do you do?
So the question was,
I think that the idea was floated that they started to fire themselves within
the compound and the ATF did not.
And that's not true.
That's not true.
They did.
They did the shit with,
with tanks.
Well,
the aerial view of the tanks just suggest something different.
I don't know.
What is the aerial view of the tanks?
Dr. Fox News suggests a vaguely using flame thrower.
I did use flame,
dude.
Okay,
let's,
let's Google use of Flint.
I mean,
I thought that was pretty established use of flame throwers and wait,
well,
from the documentary they said it,
you know the,
the big question was where was it started?
Inside the compound was the fire started by the Waco call members or by the ATF
Hidden Waco
footage.
Tanks used flame throwers and there's a link and you can go to the youtube video
and the Youtube video is unavailable and trusting proves it's bullshit.
Uh,
Waco tank,
flame thrower on Youtube,
third hole is made at the front door to sounds like some chem trail.
Shit.
Each picture is collapsing.
Oh,
that's a thing.
When you read the,
when the Internet,
you don't know
all of them.
Footage proves beyond any doubt that the tanks intentionally set the house on
fire.
It proves that the branch Davidians were murdered.
Watch carefully as the tank backs out of the house.
Watch carefully as a tank.
Backs out of the house.
Tank has a gas jet on the front that shoots fire.
Oh,
that is true.
Google Waco tank,
flame thrower.
This is pretty fucked up,
Brian.
I think this is going to turn you over.
You're going to be working for CNN.
I know you guys.
You're going to be in Ted Turner's pocket.
Fox News is going to fucking fire you.
Yeah,
you're gonna.
You're gonna go dark on this one.
You're going to go left wing.
I know is I got my deer tags,
my friend.
I got my dear tex to hey,
watch.
This third hole is made at the front door.
Go towards like a with the ears and experience.
Picture is collapsing the inside stairwell.
Okay,
here it's good.
Keep going.
The following footage proves beyond any doubt that the tanks intentionally set
the house on fire.
It proves that the branch Davidians were murdered.
Watch carefully as the tank backs out of the house.
She sounds like she did.
This tank has a gas jet on the front that shoots fire.
You can also see the fire quite plainly.
That's true.
Tank goes into the house twice and each time as it backs out,
the fire at the gas jets is plainly visible.
Wow.
Yeah,
Dude.
Tailor that house on fire.
Wow.
Where are you at now?
Fox News.
What is a man?
I think they lived at a house on fire.
What are you feeling like Fox News?
I'll tell you that much.
Uh,
I would,
I don't know.
I,
I believe,
uh,
that they set that house on fire.
I don't,
I don't have any doubt.
You get those guys have gear geared up.
Yeah.
They got shot at some of the guys got shot.
They got men are men and they're going to be vindictive.
They're going to do whatever.
They're all so soldiers and they've given in the given an enemy.
You know that old expression.
Exactly right.
If you only have a hammer,
everything looks like a nail nail.
Yeah.
I don't have any doubt about,
okay,
but here's the question.
What do you do if you know that there's a group that's hold up and they have a
bunch of weapons?
I'm not saying he should set the place on fire and killed the kids,
but I'm saying what,
how do you handle that?
How do you,
you got a guy who's shooting at federal agents allegedly there is that the
reality,
the agents,
they were being broken into.
Agents accidentally shot at themselves.
That is a fact.
You can also hear the guy say,
I have a right to defend myself as they're breaking in.
He shoots.
So a lot of it was he was in his home,
people were coming in,
he didn't,
he didn't know who was coming into his house.
They had guns.
You know,
you can make an argument for a lot of this stuff,
so,
oh yeah.
I,
what do you do in that situation?
Do you do,
I suppose the first thing you should think about is there two things.
One is our children being abused to his,
does he have illegal weapon at an illegal arsenal?
So if those are the two cases you get a search warrant,
they tried to get in,
they were denied access,
the rest is a standoff.
I don't know that that comes out and police tactics.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean do you think that someone should be allowed to have a place like that?
Like if you believe that people should be allowed to have guns.
Like I have friends who have many
guns.
My friend Justin is like a legit bonafide gun.
Yup.
He didn't even know how many guns he has now.
What if Justin got together with 50 of his friends and they're all like him and
they rented a big fucking piece of land or they bought a big piece of land
together,
put a few houses up and then put a fence around it.
I think I'm fine with that,
right?
Because I believe in that,
you know,
freedom of assembly.
Right?
But what is that?
You've got a highly armed compound of a bunch of gun nuts.
It still falls within the confines of the law.
Now,
if that,
if they have fully automatic machine guns,
Turret guns and rockets,
you're going to go,
hold on.
Do you guys have a license for those?
And you know,
there are a whole lot of measures and then you'd have to take steps to make sure
that you don't,
you don't have an army with a bunch of illegal weapons.
There's a reason there's some weapons that are,
nothing's illegal if you have a license for it.
Do you know the thing fifth correct shot himself or was shot by his,
his people.
Really?
Yeah.
They think he was shot before he,
um,
yeah,
Koresh and about two dozen other shot themselves to death or were shot before
the fire and Gulf.
The entire compound.
Others died in the fire or the rubble of the collapsing building.
Geez,
that's dark.
The shoot out.
Yeah.
It's a crabbing.
They were fucking arm to the tits.
The branch Davidians.
God,
this is crazy.
Watch this.
They become the target of a madman.
Spirit
according to intelligent weapons in this room.
So look,
we'll shoot anyone who tries to infiltrate.
Dudes shooting through the wall.
Agent Shoulder.
They shot each other.
So the agents went in
side or directly in the lineup.
Buyer,
they're shooting.
They shot through the walls and shot their own agents.
He's blending or dash and the fallen comrades retreat.
ATF agents were killed and 16 wounded.
Fucking hey man.
16 one time to heal for dead.
That's a blood gas.
That's a blood.
That right there.
You got those guys.
Good luck.
Now you're in a war.
You want to mess around with those kind of guys who gear up.
We're already tough.
And that's their job.
And you and you killed for their friends.
I want to get it.
I wouldn't be too sympathetic either at that point.
I was one of those guys.
Right,
but devil's advocate,
this is not my,
my feelings on this.
I don't have formed feelings on us.
I don't either by the way.
But those guys broken these people's houses.
For what reason?
Uh,
apparently he was in violation.
I think of two things.
A weapons,
uh,
illegal weapons caches or whatever.
And also I think there was a warrant for the fact that he was having sex with
underage girls.
Child endangerment.
Yeah.
Child child endangerment,
which is kind of a legit,
if he's running call,
my friend used to date this chick who grew up in,
I called and she,
and he said that she would tell him horrible fucking store.
That's why a lot of guys start cults so they can get pussy.
Well didn't Koresh like had a deal where he could bang everybody's wife if he
was smart?
Yeah,
that was his thing.
His thing is he could bang everybody's white.
You could be in my,
you can be in my cult.
Here's the only catch 22 don't they always do that though?
Everybody,
Jim Jones probably banged everybody's wants to,
man.
We're all,
we're all one.
People were all love.
It's all about love.
I am the Alpha male.
I don't know what,
that's what I'm saying.
I think he was saying he's god Bro.
All right,
well there's also that they all look the same like him,
the Australian Jesus,
you can put them side by side and they're like interchangeable.
Did these weeds.
That guy's great.
This Russell Australia Duncan lifts to tool to wild was so lame.
He's just like,
I'm Jesus.
Well no,
he's Lamer than lame cause he's told two different chicks that there Mary,
like his game as he tells the chick that you're married,
that I'm Jesus and you're married like,
oh,
get the fuck out of Tom and superstitious type.
The documentary is,
well,
he's not dumb.
He's pretty clever,
right?
But for the poor girl,
he has this girl that's convinced that she's married and she's crying and she's
crying and she's talking about remembering him being on the cross.
It's fucking madness.
And then afterwards he's being interviewed by the guy.
The guy was interviewing him was pretty slick and he's like,
didn't you tell another girl that she was married?
I was like,
um,
yes,
but I was wrong.
See what I mean?
He plays shittiest excuse.
Like the shitty is,
wait bro.
I would have so much of a better way.
I can lie right now and come up with a better idea.
Yes.
But I was wrong.
But it's even better than that.
He plays Green Day.
He's seen there and he's playing a green day song.
He's incredible.
You telling me that the Australian Jesus would be really in the green bay?
Like I just got to think there's gotta be a better song for him.
I don't know.
He's got like six followers.
He's got quite a few really devoted.
It's in Queensland.
He's got to crying and said he's got a giant compound and it's getting bigger.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people are very worried about him.
Really?
Yes.
I mean,
he's a legit cult leader.
Wow.
I mean he really has,
I mean it's an enormous,
I just feel like it's a huge magnet for the dummies with this society.
So there's a lot of,
it's like kind of like fly paper where it's just get all the,
it just sucks.
All the really dumb people in one area.
It's fine.
Let them know it's not,
it's not because then they can take over.
See the thing about having a really big group of dumb people as a big group of
people that are so dumb,
they don't even know they're dumb.
So there's no leaders.
There are a giant map of retarded followers and they're chasing after a guy
who's a fake Jesus who likes Green Day.
I mean this is like the numbers that a guy like that can draw.
The reason why it's fucked up.
It's because if you look at the whole population,
let's just go with America,
cause I don't know how big Australia is,
but if America's 300 million people,
what percent do you think are just
so fucking dumb?
They almost can't think things through for themselves.
I'd say it's 1% that's all you need.
If you have 1% in America,
you have 3.5 million dummies.
That is a staggering number of dummies.
If you really laid it out like that,
if it's truly one out of a hundred which is probably being super generous
because the human race,
but if it really is one out of a hundred that's 3.5 million in this country
alone,
you don't need that many to start a good call.
Shit.
Yeah.
But what does that call doing?
Aren't they just kind of living the Gospel and,
and is Jesus like Dayton?
Right?
There's a lot of sex.
He's uh,
he's got a lot going on,
man.
He's got a big ass place.
How big is it?
Um,
he used to be an Australian,
a it specialist there in Queensland's.
I mean,
it's not like Queensland is,
you know,
he's got a big spot dude,
he's just separately Monday,
Queensland.
But whatever.
I think he has like 600 acres or something up there.
That's where they find the monster great whites.
That's where they find great whites that are 22 feet that have a bite out of
them from a bigger great white
600 acres or something like that.
Cause Koresh.
Let's see.
They always have good hair.
Look at Duncan Trussell caress was actually a good looking guy.
Yeah.
Koresh was in bad looking.
No great hair.
Scruff.
But they look similar.
If you look at him and then pull up the Australian.
Jesus.
No,
not trolley Manson.
The Australian.
Jesus.
That guy looks very similar.
I'm going to cut my hair for our hunting trip.
Dude.
I'm looking at your head.
You're going to go crazy in it down.
Bring it down.
I'll do it.
Yeah.
We're going to,
what time are we going?
I'm all,
let's not,
sorry.
Sorry.
Sorry about all the personal stuff.
This guy,
um,
yeah,
he has 600 plus acres,
chilling cult transcript,
whatever.
That's a lot of fucking Queensland.
But he looked so much.
Look at him,
Brian.
Oh he looks so much like Koresh.
Ah,
he's so he's got sharp features.
Maybe it is correct,
but look at them.
Escape to both.
Got that weird beard where they can't grow up man's beard.
So they grow this fucking yes,
correct.
Might have gotten his nose sharpened.
It could be him and his hair straightened.
I think that's Kuresh stock control.
Dunkin Dunkins more wild eyed.
I'm telling you,
this guy is so silly.
When you got into that,
he,
when he got into that health thing that uh,
when he was like hanging out with the Church of Satan guy though.
That was hilariously funny though.
He does it for funny,
but it was funny.
I remember when he did that show for the uh,
heading.
Yeah.
For which guy?
Anton Levay Sun was hilarious.
Hank third.
Hank Williams Jr Danzig.
Junior.
Junior,
Hank the third played there.
Yeah.
It was just all crazy chaos man.
Who's your favorite front man?
All the time.
For what rock?
Yup.
I don't know.
I never thought about it.
What are we in high school?
Who Do you,
who's your favorite doing?
What do you think is the greatest was yours.
You must have one.
Otherwise he wouldn't have started either Robert plant or Freddie Mercury,
but I'm not sure.
I'm toss up between the two.
Yeah.
Robert Plant's right up there.
You know,
nobody had Mick Jagger's right up there too though.
Mick Jagger's up there.
But the problem with the stones,
and no one's gonna like to hear this,
they don't,
right.
They had a lot of shitty songs and the song well in forever,
but they had some fucking monsters.
They had a few monsters.
But when you pick up their albums,
like there's a bunch of Zeppelin songs that no one talks about that are fucking
phenomenal,
you know,
you'll,
you'll listen to them,
you're like,
Ooh,
I forgot about this.
You know,
this is still a beautiful,
and then you have some stone song.
You're like,
what is this?
Shut this fucking thing off.
Yeah.
I think definitely as the number one,
Ben.
Yeah,
but didn't Zeplin steal a lot?
13 songs.
They didn't credit and they didn't credit.
Oh either old time folk songs or blues or musicians that we,
they were influenced,
I mean dazed and confused and that certain songs where,
I mean if you hearing or a direct rip off and never credited them.
We played that and we do,
we play the both of them back to back.
There was a video that had a,
all the old blues songs,
like the lyrics from them and then made him a lot better though.
I mean,
and a lot better.
It just seems like those guys should've got something if there were still alive
and they did,
they went back and they um,
there was some settle out of court,
but you know,
sit.
They Fox News,
Fox News.
I Hate Fox News.
I'm really mad at you would work for them.
I would be like that Alan Colmes billion years more manly.
I'd be like,
you can have like the left wing guy on.
I'll fuck guys.
I just be fair man.
What they made you wear a dress like those hot girls.
You're not,
I don't think they're fair.
I don't think they're fell.
No,
I don't.
I think that they,
I don't like getting my news from an ideological point of view.
I'd rather get BBC,
I listen to BBC.
You do you think it's possible to have a news channel on television that's
undefined?
It doesn't slam left.
It doesn't slap right.
That at least was the model and that was I think the BBC and a lot of ways it
comes very close to it.
Maybe I'm wrong,
but but not there.
I'm talking about here in good old us of that.
I think it is the land of the free home of the brave is in fact one of the
things that they had,
the guy who was the guy who ran 60 minutes came in and said,
good news and bad news.
Good news is we got the highest rating of any new show ever.
Bad News is we got the highest rating of any new show ever.
In other words,
this just turned into a show that's dependent on ratings.
That's why we're all going to get paid a lot more money.
Well,
that's the infinite growth paradigm,
right?
It exists in corporations and it also exists on shows.
They want the ratings to go up.
The ratings are up,
up,
up.
Yeah.
So 100%,
when you see shit on Isis has guys on come on a show.
That's him being a Fox show.
Yeah,
you're on Fox.
You're the fuckers sabotage me.
That was,
that was that morning show to promote my,
my standards.
Not the same.
That's not real.
Fox Fox,
that's Emmett political shows are the weirdest fucking form of show business.
It feels local morning shows and it's changed markets.
These local shows are the weirdest form of show business ever.
Yeah,
some of them are great.
Yup.
And some of them are so bad.
You can't believe this isn't a school play.
You're like,
I am on a school play with cameras on it.
Well,
I love the journey.
A lot of them are just so bubbly and just,
it's just strange man.
Just fake dude.
And some of them are so bad.
I went on one won't name the name.
Um,
immediately guys,
first question was,
so,
um,
what was it like when Phil Hartman was killed?
And I just Sorta,
I started blank faced him.
I go was terrible.
Like one,
one word answer.
Like I'm gonna give you a one word answer for that.
I'm not going to elaborate and expand,
but that's his opening question.
It's like you saw that video where Mike Tyson was talking to the guy in Canada
and the fucking opening statement that guy says,
is this going to hurt the mayor because you were,
you went to jail for rape.
You're convicted rapist,
rapist or convicted rapist.
Yeah.
I couldn't believe that right away.
Cheap shot.
What is shitty cheap shot that's,
people love doing that shit.
They love doing that shit.
I think Mike Tyson handled it appropriately.
The handled it the right way.
A piece of shit.
So what's more stressful?
I was dealing with a piece of shit that you thought a positive here,
but you'll be even your piece of shit.
Yeah.
That dude was terrified.
He looked into the eyes of death.
Yeah,
man.
And Tyson didn't even fuck it.
His heart didn't even skip a beat.
There wasn't like an extra beat to it.
Everything stayed nice and calm.
Change that guy.
He's probably wondering whether or not I should be the show.
This guy on the air,
he's already cussing him down.
He's not going to beat him up,
but it's probably there floating around.
I'd be like if he just launched himself on this guy and just smashed his face
and it would feel so good for those brief seconds.
How much time would you have to do too much?
Not Worth it.
Don't do it.
Am I making him more famous?
He would go to jail for sure.
He imagined my,
well we'd be in Canada if you could get across the border real quick.
I thought we'd extradite him.
It's true actually.
Especially if the guy really did the guy moved at all and some sort of a
threatening way.
Call him a convicted rapist is the guy,
if he could get the guy to raise his hands up,
like just anything where it looks like the guy I did.
I did.
I did one of those things and after I'd done the hangover two and they asked me
about the experience and I started talking about the lady boys and how you know,
and they're,
it's a family show.
And I started saying,
look,
I mean I'm a straight man,
but those lady boys looked very female.
Man.
Did they get nervous?
They changed the subject and okay,
well that's the way you have not going to go there.
Well that's Brian can will be at such and such tonight and tomorrow.
And I got Jesus.
You got to shut me down real quick.
He live in a world of no fun.
It's really smelled of everything has to be like formal.
All right,
let's go over here to the board and take a look at the weather.
Well,
what we've got here is a cold front moving in.
That same
guy has to do everything.
That same guy has to do Tom Cruise in a bit of a blow up with Matt Lauer.
Oh,
we'll tell you about it when we get back.
Like who are you?
I know you don't exist in nature.
It's the strangest thing guys.
You just talk as though everything is just fantastic.
There's certain people that you know shouldn't exist in nature and they offend
you.
They're,
they're offensive and that's a fee.
There's something about that.
They're like,
okay,
I'll let you read the news,
I'll,
I'll let you,
I'll let you be the robot.
But if you fuck and try to give your opinion as that robot,
well,
you know,
these days are different than when we were kids and a guy like ray rice,
she just know better.
Like,
okay,
what do you do?
You just,
you just talked about some important shit and some weird fucking fake,
I was just talking about that,
about why I have a visceral kind of reaction to that kind of shit.
And I wonder if it's maybe because historically those kinds of dudes cock block
people.
Well they were also a liability,
right?
Fuck yeah.
Like you need somebody you can rely on when you go hunt for food or you got to
go to battle or whatever it might be,
which was mankind's history.
I wonder if those kinds of people were always people you basically,
cause when they talk that way,
they're not talking to you.
I don't trust you.
You're not being,
you know,
being real with me so I can't rely on you.
I think that's what it is.
I mean,
that's what I happened to me.
Even when I see a guy who's dressed super cool,
like there's a lot of time spent on,
he's watching himself.
I go,
oh boy.
I don't know man,
that looks good on you.
But I,
I'm just having a problem with that necklace and that hat too many rings on,
you've got too many rings on Matt really talked to you wearing like six rings.
I can't talk to you can't ultimately be friends with you.
That's my problem.
That
character you can't trust.
Like that's Dr. Smith from lost in space.
Right.
You can never count on Dr. Smith.
Oh do you will be a will.
He would give you up.
He would give you up to the aliens.
That's right.
If the aliens were going to kill him,
they like,
I'll tell you what they,
oh,
I'll tell you where they are.
And you're like,
Dr. Smith,
you fuck.
And the Dad who was always like rock solid with a square jaw kept letting Dr.
Smith and his silly little homo,
I'll let them back in.
Dr. Smith was clearly gay.
Never wanted to have anything to do with the wife,
was not,
I mean he was alone with no women.
He never did.
Never flirted with her and never imagined what it would be like.
He never said to him,
you're married.
I was just no women out here in space.
I mean,
you've got the best woman on earth.
There's nothing weird or creepy happened.
He was clearly an untrustworthy gay men.
It's probably one of the most homophobic characters ever because he was so weak.
He wasn't he me,
first of all,
he always watched the kids.
Like the guy was always watching the kids while the dad,
who was the fucking astronauts superhero was fucking saving the planet.
He was at hand.
He was sort of a hen.
Yeah.
He was a hen and he was weak.
He was so weak.
He was clearly gateway.
He told,
oh,
deal will.
He was just weak.
Yeah.
And clearly gay.
Like it was such a homophobic character,
but that was the only way anybody would ever accept a character like that on
television.
Yeah.
He had to have it.
He had to be feminized.
Yeah.
Like if he was in that position and he couldn't be trusted,
but he was very masculine and,
and,
and you know,
he'd be banging the astronauts white you when it would be a conflict.
Well,
after a while,
you're not even an Alpha male at home while you're gone off on expeditions.
It's,
something's going to happen.
Weird Shit would happen.
Yeah.
Especially if the dudes on trustworthy,
I mean,
especially if you're in space,
like you got no shot at getting back to civilization.
How many seasons did they do?
I have to a couple of years ago to realize this is where we going to live out
here on the moon for a fucking room.
Hundred Years.
This blows the kids.
They have to fucking listen to this guy.
They're falling around with them and they have to go back.
Dad,
Daddy's lion.
Yeah.
That might start banging him having like any,
any sort of person in that sort of a completely artificial way in your life.
Like you let them in.
It's like,
oh,
we're,
we,
we let in some weird shit like you've ever been up to Dan.
I know you have,
cause you,
you hang around with a bunch of idiots.
You ever been out to dinner with a guy and it's a rude thing to say,
listen,
you know,
I love you.
You're awesome.
But you hang around with fucking massive thing.
That's Dodos I've known Brian for so long that I know not to go over to his
house when he'll tell me like,
sir,
he's a good guy.
He just,
uh,
you know,
he's just a little weird or something.
And He'd come over his house for some party and you're talking next to some
loon,
like,
Oh God,
Brian,
what are you doing hanging out with this guy?
I know,
I know.
He wants to borrow money,
which should I tell him?
Tell him no,
the fuck you doing.
You'd always have like some new person you were hanging around with liquid waste
here in my life.
Do that producer,
producer guy that used to hang around with.
When I first started hanging around with Brian,
he had this producer guy that he hung around with and I remember like some guy
was like a writer who was trying to like make some things happen.
Meetings,
you don't need to name names.
You know what I'm talking about?
African American descent.
Oh yeah.
Complete total hustler and all boy.
And I was like,
wait,
what?
How did this guy get in this guys really close and I saw that.
Oh Man.
Kept hanging out with those around me.
You pitch shows with him.
He loved me.
He showed up drunk.
Yeah.
Drunk like,
well that guy was a,
he believed he was smart.
He believed he was like smart and slick and he was going to pull it off and he
believed like his smiles and his charm would mask the overall like slickster
hustler bullshit that he had underneath.
But there was,
there was no substance.
Like he would pitch ideas,
he'd be like,
what is this idea?
This dog shit idea you guys are going to go out with.
He was just was all like energy and he had found a way to integrate himself into
Hollywood,
you know?
And there's a bunch of those dudes,
man.
And he used to always have them around you.
Some of those people in Hollywood,
how many of those dudes did I tell you?
Dude,
you need to get the fuck away from those guys about how much time I would have
saved if I didn't get involved with those days.
But then I'd probably find other dudes,
you know what I mean?
Like,
like there would always be someone,
and I think it's a personality trait where I,
I would be pot I,
you know,
it's almost like if you're like me,
maybe because you moved around so much,
you make friends really quickly and you see the good only and then you just do
there to have a good time.
And then slowly you go,
oh wait,
you're a complete fucking,
you're a liar or whatever.
Yeah.
Well we have,
you have great.
I'd save so much time if I have your antenna.
I view or engineering when you were a genuine,
no,
my antenna's not flawless man.
There's a dude that slipped through the wire.
There's a couple people that slipped through the war that one of them was that
Raphael Tory guy.
I didn't really know him though.
I can't really,
I don't know,
was friends with uh,
Eddie Bravo and uh,
he turned out to be a fake Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt and he murdered some
guy.
He's in jail right now for murder.
He murdered some guy.
He was like banging the guy's wife and then like they had an insurance policy or
something and he killed the guy.
Yeah.
And was driving the guy's car.
There's some crazy shit was going on.
But when I met him,
he didn't seem like a murder to me.
Man.
He seemed pretty fucking normal and I didn't ever see him do martial arts,
so I couldn't see like,
whether it was bullshit or not,
I just met him at like a king of the cage event and talk to him.
But then you find out the guy's like a murderer and now he's in jail.
For what?
Yeah,
how was,
okay shit.
Maybe if I had a deal with them,
maybe I had something going on where w you know,
we were involved in something together.
Some business transaction or something.
Maybe I could have seen the bullshit pay,
but those guys are slick.
That's their job.
But he wasn't that slick because I did eventually watch a video long after Edie
had outed them it or told him like,
get the fuck out.
Eddie figured out that he wasn't really a black belt.
It was before Eddie was even a black belt and he was like purple belt or a brown
belt at the time.
It was before he beat Heuler.
It was long before that,
but we were um,
we were in the car once and Eddie fucking broke them down over the phone while
we were in the car.
Really?
Yeah.
The guy kept trying to hustle and,
and Diego,
stop,
stop.
Are you a black belt in Jujitsu?
I just need to hear this right now.
And there was this pause and he would start some other nonsense and this that,
well,
my dad learned Japanese.
You just stop,
stop,
stop.
Do you actually have a black belt in Jujitsu?
Not Your Dad,
not who you trained with.
[inaudible] and he went and there was like a silent moment and he goes,
I don't want to talk to you ever again.
Okay,
you're a bullshit artist like you,
you,
you made me,
I brought you around people you made me look bad.
Like you're not being honest.
You're not.
You're not honest person.
So after all that,
then I saw a video,
the dude working out,
I saw a video of him doing like a spinning back kick on a pad.
It's fucking comical.
I mean it's like someone showed him 20 minutes before.
Wow.
Busy.
Ridiculously bad.
But he had a crazy story.
This guy,
he,
he was such a hustler.
So it's a bullshit artist that he turned.
He turned up at,
he told this guy,
I need you to give me a ride in the woods.
I'm going to this no rules,
karate,
Kuma Tay and a,
I'm going to be gone for a couple of days.
So,
uh,
come back and get me a liquor on Saturday.
So he has his big duffle bag with them.
Okay.
Big fucking full duffle bag.
And he takes it with him.
He goes off this Cooma day and then the guy comes back on Saturday and now he's
holding a trophy.
How's it got?
Pick them up at the same spot.
He says,
yeah,
one that's tay and Pete,
everybody and nothing.
I got a trophy.
And the guy's like,
how you a fucking had a duffle bag that was filled with this fucking trophy?
Oh No.
He told me to come get you in two days.
So he probably would walked home,
took a nap,
aids and food,
went back up.
Wait for the dude to pick them up,
you know,
and yeah,
man,
a at the trophy I won.
You never know.
Like my buddy Mitch told me this crazy story.
He goes back to the high school reunion and one of the craziest today was his
guy Fitzy and Fitzy used it like he'd get on a car and you could drive 70 miles
an hour.
He's holding on it.
He was just crazy,
always the fun guy.
And he'd fight and get crazy.
So,
um,
and he was the sort of hometown,
crazy,
fun,
fucking nutty kid.
Good kid,
fun and crazy.
So Mitch goes back to his high school reunion in Tennessee and he says,
where the fuck is Fitzy?
And,
uh,
his cousin fits his cousin goes,
Ahh,
Bra.
It's a bad story,
man.
And he goes,
what do you mean he goes,
fits?
He's in jail,
man.
And he goes,
what are you fucking for?
What?
And he goes,
ah,
and everybody got weird.
And he goes,
it's just,
he's just there for a while and,
you know,
it's not coming out for a long time.
What the fuck did he do?
Well,
turns out Fitzy um,
kept going to Applebee's and there was a waiter there and he would,
the waiter would wait on them and Fitzy and he became friends.
And so one day fits.
He said,
let's go to the cornfields and smoke a joint and hang out.
And so we'll do joint and Fitz.
He tries to end,
does rape him and then tries to kill him after raping him.
A fight ensues.
Mr Applebee's runs through the Cornfield,
gets away and goes,
um,
the authorities please.
I was just a raped in attempt to murder.
They've tried,
tried to murder me.
He was all cut up and stuff and well,
it fits.
He's in jail now.
That's a weird thing.
Tried to fuck a guy.
Fucking kill a guy.
It's not what you're here.
And hung out with a guy for a long time at Applebee's and befriended them and
had actually planned the whole thing.
Oh my gosh.
So you never know,
gentlemen.
You never know how crazy somebody fucking is.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
The Fun Guy,
he's fun was the fun guy.
Hey buddies here.
He's got a rock.
He's got a belly flop off the high dive.
Ooh.
Ah,
yeah.
And now I'm going to fuck
you.
Oh God.
Yeah.
Oh,
so who knows?
We were fucking notes.
Yeah.
Those guys when he grow up to like,
you know,
you grow up in a neighborhood and it's like 50 dudes,
whatever,
that all kind of know each other like that.
The potential for one fucking unbelievably crazy person is so strong,
so strong,
especially if you're in the city.
Have you ever seen that video of the kid who does a back flip off the top of a
second story building?
No.
Yup.
Wild Kid in the street,
you know there's always those wild kids will try anything.
I have seen that this guy does and he makes it the first time it does it again.
Oh,
I didn't know about that.
Yeah.
The one that I've seen,
I've only seen one when a guy makes it and he's hanging out in a diner
afterwards and I was like,
how the fuck did you do that?
He backed,
backed this back to the edge and then just flipped.
Flipped to the air.
Land isn't collapse in the ground was fine.
It's one of the most incredible things.
It's the craziest Shit I've ever seen.
Did it for a zero?
Didn't do it for a nickel.
I mean,
maybe he had a bat,
but whatever.
I Dunno.
But it's the craziest thing I've ever,
I mean,
I remember that gone.
Oh,
that's the craziest thing.
I've seen that shit.
That's what happens when people grow up together and one guy pushes another guy
and the next thing you've got a steevo craziness.
The Hawk like Steevo like you got some crazy funny.
Knoxville is the most gnarly.
They're all crazy.
But look,
Steve O was with lions.
He climbed a fucking tree and the lions came up the tree and their swat and they
took his hat from him that is talked about that.
And that was a commercial he was doing.
And he said,
do they climb trees now?
Don't worry,
they don't climb trees.
And when Steve was up there,
the lion climbed up the tree and got on Tom and Steve as well,
I'm going to die now.
And the trainer took a raw chicken and wave to that day,
Lyon and got him away.
But Steve would tell us,
tell the story.
Whereas Johnny Knoxville will blindfold himself with a cigarette in his mouth
and allow a bowl to run through him.
I saw that.
Oh,
I haven't seen this one.
Is this another kid?
Five story.
No fluff into a pool.
Oh,
no way.
Why do I not want to see this?
I don't either.
It makes me so nervous because you're going to die.
It's on any bomb thrower.
This,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
That's,
that's a bad motherfucker.
Oh my God.
That's a bad motherfucker.
Please don't do that at home you guys.
Please don't do that.
Anybody.
Maybe I'm,
please don't do that.
It's crazy.
What is it feel like when he was in the air,
like what have I done?
I don't know.
Imagine what that felt like on his balls because your feet hit and then you're,
what's funny is he's not in the air for that.
Bob.
So crazy.
Like how,
how,
how fast you fall.
Like do it again.
How many seconds was he in the,
not very long.
Don't much.
Your voice just got high again.
I do too scared when I used to do the fear factor stunts in the real look,
looking over the edge of some of the buildings these people had to crawl out on.
I'm like,
oh,
is this another one?
Oh No,
dude,
what is this now?
Oh No,
stop it.
Oh my God,
this guy's going to climb or he's going to swing.
This is not good.
I don't know,
man.
I'm still thinking.
I want to see this.
Well,
I do now.
Um,
why?
What's wrong with you?
Because so it's not even in another country.
You got to push yourself as a different language.
Die For sure.
Why are you doing?
Oh my God.
Look at this again.
What's the image?
Oh No,
no,
no.
So crazy.
He barely,
barely made it.
Look at that.
What a jump though.
That's insane.
He missed by like,
uh,
I mean,
I don't even want to see any cheese.
He would've smashed his knees apart.
I had trouble sleeping with that.
Do you know that's an interesting thing.
There was a study on why men do that and they were trying to figure out what it
is about men that makes them want to do like ridiculous stunts like that.
And they said that when men do that,
it makes them more sexually attractive to females.
There's certain females that are attracted to men that don't have fear though,
or willing to overcome fear and that it's somehow or another they think in some
way connected to the idea of a brave warrior.
Cause a brave warrior faces something that everyone else is terrified but faces
it head on.
And that same sort of like reaction to watching someone do something that you
know as a person is absolutely terrified when they see it.
It gets them turned on.
I get it.
Makes total sense to me.
I think that's just a misplacement of energy.
I mean that guy would have been,
you know,
okay,
that's a misplacement but isn't that essentially,
I'm just saying that that,
that he is back in the day he probably would have been with a shield and
charging into battle.
That's what I mean.
Well,
I mean,
isn't it?
What I was saying is,
isn't it essentially the same thing that makes someone like a crazy BMX rider?
You do those flips.
Yeah,
man.
That's kind of the same thing.
It's just,
it's also pushing yourself beyond what you think you can do,
but you know,
but the BMX guy gets money.
If your BMX guy and you,
you do flips and shit and you're awesome at it,
you can make a lot of money.
I also think it's juice.
It's also dry adrenaline.
Look,
man,
getting into a ring every day and fight and do is where you might get knocked
out.
That's,
that's pretty daredevily as well.
That's pretty scary too.
Oh No,
no running ponds back in the NFL.
Fucking scary.
Yeah.
Any of that shit.
You know,
something about that is leak.
You like when you're fighting,
at least you're under your own sort of control in some sort of a way.
Yeah,
you have to deal with somebody else,
but if you know what the fuck you're doing,
you can kind of mitigate a lot of shit,
sort of.
You at least you hope you can.
That's the ultimate goal.
But man,
when you're fucking doing flips off a mountain,
going off a mountain or a mountain bike,
I
wish,
Bam,
and then your landing,
some of those guys are out of their fucking mind.
I think you get addicted to the adrenaline to 100% yeah,
the most.
I mean,
if I didn't perform,
I would die.
Yeah.
But I think it's a way crazier rush that they get.
They're doing like two flips on TV and landing on a bike.
They do motorcycles,
they flip through the air on a motorcycle.
But then what happens?
What happens when that goes away?
You know?
Well,
what happens when it lands on their body?
That's a horrible to watch.
Well,
Jason Ellis,
Jason Ellis still has to do crazy shit.
You got in the ring with,
with Keith Jardine the other day and he just putting a mouthpiece,
no headgear and goes,
let's just slug it out.
And he starts going at it with Giardia and Giardia and just cause all right.
You know what?
Bang,
just catches him with an uppercut,
knocks him out.
Jason was like,
it was fucking awesome.
He just needs the juice.
I was like,
but that's Chardyna hit you and knocked you out.
That's not good for your brain.
He's been,
he's been shut off a bunch of times too.
Yeah.
I asked him about that once and he said he's been alcohol like six times and
that was black.
I think there was like from skateboarding,
I don't even think that was from fighting.
I know he loves doing it.
Sturdy Dude,
man.
Yeah,
but that causes depression.
Like too much head trauma like that.
Yeah.
That causes,
that causes you to route do like shit.
You Claire shooting themselves in the chest so that you can study their brain
because they knew something was wrong.
Mark Gordon,
I'm the guy,
uh,
who's the expert in traumatic brain injury.
Dr. Mark Gordon,
he,
um,
he said it doesn't take much and he said,
you could have one wrong car accident where you don't even get injured.
You just slammed forward and like hit the steering wheel.
Like,
you're fine.
Everybody's fine,
everybody's fine.
You know,
a little fender bender and you're fucked.
You're fucked.
You're depressed for months.
You don't know why your pituitary gland just not functioning properly.
Like you're,
you're bringing so by a lot of people with brain injury go on hormone therapy
because their body starts producing testosterone and that stuff.
Yeah,
well there's a bunch of shit.
The,
your dopamine levels drop your serotonin levels drop your human growth hormone
levels drop,
you get tired.
You know,
they think that that's a lot of what they used to call chronic fatigue syndrome
to chronic fatigue syndrome.
They attribute to a couple of different possibilities.
One of them has Lyme disease.
They didn't understand the Lyme disease.
Well,
I'm disease.
They believe I didn't start diagnosing people with Lyme disease to like the
fucking eighties or something like that.
It was fairly recent disease.
Um,
but the other one,
they think it might have been depression and head trauma where they just don't
want to get out of bed.
Like that's,
remember that when they used to call it chronic fatigue syndrome,
it was called up.
I mean,
they had different words for it,
but you know,
was like a Epstein Barr virus.
My roommate in college had that for like a year.
Yeah.
It's just,
you know,
had to,
I remember there was some girl that,
um,
I didn't know,
but I knew her like peripherally and someone was like,
yeah,
poor girl,
she's got chronic fatigue syndrome.
I'm like,
what the fuck is that?
And I think,
yeah,
I don't know if she had been a car accident or something,
but if I want to say she was,
it's like a serious car accident.
I'm trying to remember.
It's too,
it's too long ago.
I might be confusing stories,
but I remember thinking like I had met her before and she seemed normal and now
here she is.
What?
She doesn't have any energy to do anything.
When you have somebody who's breakdown,
like just what one Oregon does and then how it,
how it works with all the other organs.
Sometimes you can't believe that shit doesn't break down more.
Yeah.
It's like it's just such an intricate machine and one thing is dependent on the
other.
It's fucking nuts where somebody will have a cavity and issue with their tooth
and they have unexplained foot pain and all of a sudden they realized that the
nerve in the tooth is connected to the nerve in the foot.
And so what was really causing the problem,
the pain in your foot was not your foot.
It was what was your,
it was your tooth like an infection.
Infection.
There's a,
there's a certain nerve that goes from,
from like the jaw all the way down.
You know,
people get fucking heart attacks for tooth infections.
Yes.
It caused the artery.
The bacteria corrodes the arteries.
Crows,
the crows,
the valves.
Yeah.
It's fucking,
you know,
that's why there's a bullet thing is so fucking frightening because anything
that just to mediafly shuts your body down.
Anything that immediately puts your body into a tailspin.
50% of the people that catch this shit die.
Yeah.
It's so weird when something just goes wrong.
Like everything's great today.
Today.
What did I do?
Wow.
I went and walked the dogs.
I,
uh,
I got up,
I play with my kid.
I bumped up a bow or went and played tennis.
What happened yesterday?
Oh,
you know,
same thing.
What happens tomorrow?
Ebola.
Yeah.
See it.
Boom.
Magic virus boils all over your face.
Your face is covered in a giant fucking cell phone size plus
fine
crying out of your eyes.
It's like seeing,
um,
that woman who went jogging and Florida and she was,
you know,
it was like seven at night and she had a long day at work.
She went right and she's just dangled a feed off the bridge.
I just got to dangle my feet.
I'm just fucking hot.
And an 11 foot alligator was like,
I'm going to,
I'll take you now.
I'll be having you now.
Oh,
they found it with no arms.
Took her arms.
Fuck.
That's good time.
Alligator was like,
I know I'm an alligator and usually I don't do this cause the crocodiles do it.
I'm going to do it today to you.
You're going to be,
uh,
the third,
only three people or four people of the year that's going to be eaten by a
fucking 11 foot dragon.
That'll be me.
You the weird that alligators,
they let them hang around because they're not too aggressive.
It's like they're just docile and usually run from you that people don't just
decide to fucking kill them onsite.
But really everyone in Florida should be in up in arms.
They should run out to the swamps and gun those fucking dinosaurs down.
Like those are a bunch of kid eating dog eating monster shit out of dogs.
And a guy was walking his dog and they all get it.
Didn't go for the dog.
Went for the guy.
Took the guy's fucking Jesus.
Yeah.
They're just not as aggressive as crocs.
If they were crocs,
we wouldn't be killing them.
Left slide crocodiles,
they found Nile crocs in the everglades.
Stop it.
Yes,
they have.
There's a shoot on order for Nile Crocodile.
People used to have them as pets.
Nile crocodiles,
they don't know if they're breeding.
They don't don't have any idea,
but their spot in more than one Nile crocodile in the everglades confirmed
sightings.
They're saying straight up killers.
Yep.
If you see them,
they kill him onsite.
Straight up come,
they will come right at you.
You are food as a human being.
Oh,
they get really big.
That peace corps girl who was like,
oh they were in Kenya.
Well,
the crocodiles died out,
uh,
years ago.
She heard,
she heard,
she goes swimming.
The guy's like,
I don't know.
She's like,
I'm going in with a value.
I'm a water baby.
30 seconds later it's pulled on a cloud.
Got My feet.
There was a document or an article I was reading about these people that were
canoeing in the Congo and the guy behind washes,
the guy in front gets taken by the crock with a Croc,
just rises up out of the water and literally snatches the guy and spins the
canoe upside kayak rather.
[inaudible] stuck in it and it like goes up and down like a bobber and then pump
and then pops up.
No Guy,
that's it.
He doesn't see the guy over again.
The CROC just takes them out of the water.
And just so the motto of that story is don't fucking Kayak in denial.
I mean in,
in the Congo it don't do that.
That would be the motto of that story.
Oh,
fucking are you out of your fucking mind?
They're not like sharks.
They will bother you.
They come after you come after everything.
Yeah.
That's what they're,
they're here for cleanup.
Ologists sit in Uganda.
He saw,
saw what a crock.
I'll eat a god damn tire.
Eat a whole tire.
I was like,
I'm going to heat this tire.
can you repeat that again?
He goes,
it ain't a tire.
Cartera cause yet eight.
Oh my God.
So your your food.
Yeah,
they eat everything.
That's tee shirt,
everything.
If you think about it like where are they?
Well,
they live in a place that's so rich with life and they have to be consistent in
their ability to kill it like that.
Did a cleanups anytime.
Just too many water buffaloes.
There's too many wildebeests when there's too many Willdabeast they'd go near
the waterhole and they get [inaudible].
They get snatched it.
Right.
But you know,
it doesn't get snatched.
Hippos crocs don't fuck with absolutely that.
All hallows Wade into the water with crocs and swim right by him.
It's the most amazing thing to say because hippos are so fucking violent.
They're like,
go fuck yourself.
They break crocs in half.
They cut crocs in half.
Yeah.
We're at a time.
That's it.
I have no more time,
Brian.
Killen you are my friend.
You are the shit.
You are hilarious.
If people want to see Brian,
it's B r y a.
N.
Callen.
Has Anybody taken br I a n count.
Just start taking pictures of dicks.
I don't know,
man.
I don't know.
Pr.
Y,
B r.
Y a n Callan on Twitter.
All right,
my friend.
Much love anything.
Just tell people were,
where were you going to be getting?
I'll be in that Atlanta Improv October 16th,
17th,
18th to come see me.
Go see him.
Solaris.
Yeah.
Very funny.
Stand up,
Brian.
You got anything going on?
Columbus,
Ohio and grand rapids,
Michigan and Indianapolis.
Uh,
you just got death squad.
Dot TV.
Click on tour dates.
Desk,
squad.
Dot.
TV.
Click on tour dates.
That's it.
You fucks.
We'll see you soon.
Much love [inaudible] one,
one,
one la.